Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
You posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton,
which I've been using probably for about a year now.
Peloton is a cutting edge indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home.
You can also do on demand,
which is what I do.
We'll come back to that so you don't have to worry about fitting classes into a
busy schedule or making it to a studio or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute.
I,
for instance,
have a Peloton bike right in my master bedroom at home and it's one of the first
things I do.
Many mornings I wake up and meditate for a bit.
Then I knock out a short 20 minute ride in my undies.
Hard to do that at the gym,
take a shower,
and I'm in higher gear for the rest of the day.
It's really convenient and has become something that I look forward to.
See.
You have a lot of options for one if you'd like.
You can ride live with thousands of other writers across the country on an
interactive leaderboard to keep him motivated.
There are also up to 14 new classes added every day with more than 8,000 classes
on demand and you can pick based on length,
45 minutes,
20 minutes,
whatever music,
hip hop,
rock and roll or say low impact versus high intensity or interval.
You can pick the class structure and style that works for you and in my case I
quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to do on demand and listened to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and over,
but I'm kind of promiscuous and also enjoy classes from a lot of the other
instructors.
They have Peloton and amazing roster of incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and personalities so you can find what you're in
the mood for.
You also get real time metrics that you can use to track your performance over
time and that will help,
I would say,
catalyze you to beat your personal best.
Now that all sounds good,
right?
Gamification,
Yada,
Yada.
I didn't think that it would work for me or in any way incentivize me,
but they really 100% hit the nail on the head.
I was very,
very impressed with how motivating it was and it worked tremendously to keep me
pushing,
uh,
which quite honestly takes a fair amount.
I can get quite lazy,
particularly with anything that edges on endurance,
which is kind of more than five reps of anything for me.
So check it out.
Discover this cutting edge indoor cycling bike that brings a studio experience
right to your home Peloton is offering listeners to this podcast,
a limited time offer.
Go to one peloton.com that's o n e Peloton p e l o t o n.com and enter the code
Tim all caps at checkout and get $100 off of accessories with your Palestine
bike purchase.
So get a great workout at home anytime you want.
Check it out.
Go to one peloton.com and use the code Tim to get started.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom,
which more than 2 million Americans have used to help start their businesses.
Past guests even such as,
well,
wordpress lead developer,
CEO of Automattic,
Matt Mullenweg now valued at more than a billion dollars,
have used legal zoom to help with their business needs,
specifically in his case to form his company,
but legal zoom isn't just for launching your business.
Their services include everything from helping you to manage changing tax laws,
reviewing contracts,
creating Ndas,
nondisclosure agreements,
important stuff,
handling lease agreements and assisting with really any other legal challenge,
hurdle,
inconvenience that typically takes time and effort away from running your
business.
The best part is that you won't get charged by the hour because legal zoom isn't
a law firm,
so they won't be running the clock up and spinning circles just to raise your
bill.
Instead,
they just ask you to pay one low upfront price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get all the card style.
So visit legal zoom.com and check out their business section for all of their
services.
And if you want special savings,
that's the terminology in the copy that they suggest.
I don't know what the special savings is folks,
but it's titillating.
If you want special savings,
enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout,
capital t,
lowercase.
I am again,
take a peek legal zoom.com and enter Promo Code Tim.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job each episode to interview and deconstruct world class performers
and or people who are the best of what they do to tease out the life lessons,
habits,
tools,
and so on that you can hopefully apply to your own lives.
And this episode was such a treat for me.
I had so much fun and I was able to interview a living legend.
Someone I've wanted to interview on this podcast for many years.
Stanislav Grof and we went deep.
We went long,
we went wide.
It was everything I hoped it to be.
Stanislav Grof,
MD,
otherwise known as Stan Grof.
Stanislav is spelled s.
T a.
V is a psychiatrist with more than 60 years of experience in research of
holotropic states of consciousness,
and we'll define what that means in the interview,
but suffice to say for now it is a large and important subgroup of non ordinary
states that have healing,
transformative and evolutionary potential and we will explore all of that.
Previously he was principal investigator in a psychedelic research program at
the psychiatric research institute in Prague,
Czechoslovakia,
Chief of psychiatric research at the Maryland Psychiatric Research Center,
Assistant Professor of Psychiatry at Johns Hopkins University in Baltimore,
Maryland and scholar in residence at the Esalen Institute.
In this very wide ranging conversation,
we cover a whole lot of things including some stuff that he has not gone over
previously.
So among others,
some of his main takeaways after supervising or guiding roughly 4,500 LSD
sessions,
that is LSD assisted psychotherapy sessions,
the place in role of so called wounded healers,
limitations and uses of traditional psychoanalysis and talk therapy,
similarities.
There's some similarities between holotropic breathwork and MDM may use or the
applications of Mtma stories,
a very odd synchronicities and the seemingly impossible.
We get into some very,
very hard to explain reports and phenomena to put it very,
very lightly.
Stan's strangest personal experiences on psychedelics and what Stan believes
humanity most needs to overcome.
Division and destruction.
Currently stand is professor of psychology at Ciis,
that's the California Institute of Integral Studies in San Francisco and
conducts professional training programs and hold tropic breathwork and
transpersonal psychology as well as gives lectures and seminars worldwide.
He's one of the founders and chief theoreticians of transpersonal psychology as
a field and the founding president of the International Transpersonal
Association,
Ita.
His publications include more than 150 articles in professional journals and
books like psychology of the future of the cosmic game and hold tropic
breathwork among many others.
You can find him online and I will link to this and everything in this episode
in the show notes at tim.blog/podcast.
You can find them online@stanislavgrof.com.
Now,
one more thing before we get to the interview and I'll try to keep this short.
Please,
please,
if you are a listener of this podcast,
if you like what you hear,
I invite you and uh,
ask you please to subscribe to the podcast and you will get notified whenever I
release a new episode.
For many reasons and a lot of technical reasons,
this is very,
very helpful to me and my podcast team.
It helps us to get hard to reach guests and do much more of ticks,
10 to 30 seconds.
So all you have to do is search for the Tim Ferriss show you can misspell,
it doesn't matter in iTunes or on your phone,
in the app you use like apple podcasts,
overcast,
stitcher,
castbox,
whatever.
When you see my face and the Tim Ferriss show,
click on it and click subscribe.
That's it.
Super easy.
If you can spare the 10 to 30 seconds,
thank you for pausing this episode briefly to do that.
It really helps us to do bigger and better things for you all.
And with that said,
please enjoy this interview.
I hope you enjoy it as much as I did with the one and only Stan Grof.
Stan,
welcome to the show.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.
It's such an,
I would like to thank you for everything you have been doing for raising
consciousness on this planet has been amazing and it's a great honor and
pleasure for me to be on your show.
Oh,
thank you so much.
I could not be more excited be speaking with you right now.
And we said hello via video of just a few moments ago and,
uh,
I certainly have only become more excited to have this conversation,
because of our,
our introduction Jack Kornfield,
one of the sweetest humans I know.
And uh,
I have many questions and many topics.
Uh,
so thanks of course to Jack for making the introduction.
And,
uh,
by this time people would have already heard some of your bio graphical
information that I would have read,
but I suppose we should start maybe at the beginning and ask you how you first
became interested in psychedelics.
Well,
the situation was I became initiative,
very excited about psychoanalysis and,
uh,
it is out there.
I went to medical school and in my fourth year of medical school,
I was going to the psychiatric department already as a volunteer to get some,
you know,
some,
a sense for the,
for the discipline.
And this is where we got from Santos,
a supply of ampules of Delis,
it of,
of LSD.
And it came with a letter talking about the history about the,
you know,
the famous,
uh,
experienced self experimental Albert Hofmann and the bicycle ride and all that.
And they were asking us if we would like to experiment with that substance and
let them know if there was any illegitimate use for it in a psychiatry and uh,
psychology.
And,
uh,
my preceptor,
um,
uh,
don't send her ob check who was very interested in Lsd,
but he didn't have time to sit,
uh,
you know,
for six or eight hours with this,
uh,
um,
patients,
uh,
the experimental subjects.
So he was using several of us as a kind of goal for us.
We were sitting in these sessions and we very keeping the records.
So I actually started my exposure to Lsd,
uh,
already in 1954,
but a,
unlike at Harvard students who are excluded.
So I couldn't have my own session until I graduated from the medical school.
And by the time,
you know,
my appetite was whetted.
So I was sitting in these sessions of a psychologist,
psychiatrist,
uh,
artists and,
you know,
hearing all these fantastic stories about the experiences that they had,
but I had no really no access to it.
What application were you looking at initially?
Uh,
what was,
uh,
what was the,
you know,
initially it was just a,
just a kind of a toss,
just a phenomenological,
a search that's giving it to different people and seeing what it does,
you know,
I don't know if you can now,
when there are a lot of publications and,
uh,
you know,
other kinds of publicity,
what it was like for us when the substance fell into our laps,
we had absolutely no idea what it would do,
you know,
from session to session.
I mean,
uh,
we didn't know where it would be going,
you know,
with our patients and in our own sessions.
So it was quite an exciting adventure.
I spent several years actually doing two sessions a day.
I would get up early if to a session and,
uh,
two,
two o'clock,
you know,
I started another one and I had a department where I had 18 beds and all the
patients were getting Lsd,
so they were really familiar with the states and all our nurses have training
sessions.
So by two o'clock I could pass the,
the person I was coming down from an LSD session to this team of nurses and
patients and I could start another one.
And I was sitting in all of those sessions,
you know,
all the whole time,
unlike some other places where,
for example,
on scar loin or he was just surely leaving the bay,
the experimental subjects,
uh,
alone.
And they just had a bell where they could call the nurse when they were in
trouble.
But I was so excited about what was coming on.
I realized this was,
this is going to change,
you know,
psychiatry,
psychology.
What,
what was it about those early experiences that led you to that conclusion that
it would change psychiatry and psychology?
And maybe just before we get to that,
and I want to talk about your first experience as well,
but how many total sessions have you directly or indirectly been a part of or
supervised in your life would you say at this point?
Who would be like a four and a half thousand of,
uh,
you know,
LSD sessions,
but I adult,
so I was working with silicide been also,
we were working for a while with the tryptamine derivative switch.
You actually came from Budapest,
from our neighbor,
a doctor's Zada,
Steven Zara and doctor sermon.
They were the ones who actually develop the whole group of,
uh,
the,
tryptamine derivatives,
the Mtd e t.
T.
P.
Um,
it,
I don't think they had at the time the metrics,
the DMT,
which seems to be the most,
uh,
most interesting one.
And the initial feeling that you,
that you had or the,
the initial excitement that you felt this could change psychology and
psychiatry.
Why was that?
What did you see that made you come to that conclusion?
Whether the initial was this,
uh,
you know,
approach,
which could be a cold search for toxin ex.
Um,
the way,
um,
LSD came to us was that is a substance that can mimic somehow a psychosis.
We call the initial sessions experimental psychosis.
You know,
it was called Hallucinogens psychotomimetic.
And so the excitement or that we have a model of something like schizophrenia or
the,
or the,
uh,
other kinds of psychosis.
And this made the possibility of creating a model,
which is always great to have a model in,
in science.
So,
uh,
give,
Lsd,
you know,
to a quote unquote normal subjects.
And they would spend six to eight hours in a world that seemed to be like the
world of,
uh,
of our,
patients.
And so the initial,
my initial research actually was laboratory.
I wrote one of the early papers on the role of Serotonin in a psychiatry.
And the initial research was we had a group of 40 people,
including ourselves,
mostly professionals,
psychologists,
psychiatrists,
biologists and so on.
And we had a protocol.
We would invite these people for a day,
uh,
to,
the research institute.
We would,
uh,
do really scientific work,
you know,
throwing a blood every hour on the hour,
collecting samples of urine,
doing psychological tests and uh,
and electrophysiological,
uh,
investigations.
And then we had one day when we brought,
uh,
schizophrenia patients who were matched by age,
by gender,
by,
uh,
Iq and so on with our experimental subjects.
And we are looking if these values of this psychological and physiological
biochemical tests would sort of converged with the values in schizophrenia x.
And then something amazing happened.
I found that there was incredible,
I would say in their individual inter individual variability.
So you give the same substance,
uh,
in the same dosage,
under the same circumstances and the same lousy set and setting,
which we had.
And each of those,
uh,
people would have different experiences to the point that some of them called
it,
like the moments that they get between the tests.
It was like a self analysis,
like a,
you know,
drug assisted psychotherapy,
uh,
others where just unpleasant physical symptoms.
Some of them,
uh,
had to know paranoid episodes or became hyper manic.
And for some of them,
uh,
it was the,
the,
even under those circumstances that got glimpses of ecstatic states that,
uh,
that we are very mystical and the same,
inter individual variability.
If we took the same substance at different times,
uh,
this phenomenology was completely different.
And at that point I realized this was not psychopharmacology.
We were not doing pharmacology because if you do pharmacology,
you have to have some idea what you are getting.
You know,
if you give people apomorphine you,
you expect that a lot of them will be,
uh,
what meeting if you give them,
hypnotic,
you expect them to,
to,
to sleep.
Whereas here we had no idea what would happen.
So I realized we were doing something much more interesting.
We were,
we had a catalyst that was a make made it possible to explore the depths of the
human psyche.
I realized that people were not having LSD experiences.
They were having experiences of themselves,
but they were coming from depths that,
uh,
you know,
psychoanalysis didn't know anything about.
And so at that point I just lost,
completely interested in his laboratory approach and I took it to,
uh,
to clinical work and I started giving to my patients,
you know,
in a psychotherapeutic context.
When did you have your first personal experience?
It was,
how much and what are taken?
How much did you take,
if you recall?
Uh,
this was,
uh,
actually a hundred,
a hundred micrograms.
It was on the 13th of,
uh,
of,
November,
1956.
So I was from 54,
56.
I was sitting for people.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it was a little more complicated because my preceptor or my mentioned earlier,
he was very interested in,
uh,
electroencephalography.
And um,
at the time when Lsd came,
he was the one who received it from Santos.
So at the time when it came,
he was interested in something that's called driving the brainwaves or,
and,
and training the brainwaves,
which the Eeg,
uh,
well,
it was exposing people to a very powerful stroboscopic light frequencies and
finding out if the brainwaves in the suboccipital area,
which is the,
the visual Cortex,
if the brainwaves would pick up that frequency,
if you can drive the,
or trained the brainwave.
So,
uh,
the condition for,
for us having the session with him,
we had to agree that we would have a EEG,
you know,
before,
during,
and after.
And that we also will have our brainwaves driven,
uh,
in,
in all those sessions.
So what happened that,
uh,
you know,
between the third and the fourth hour,
when the session,
uh,
usually culminated,
the,
uh,
Doctor Ob checks assistant came and she said,
it's time to drive the brainwaves.
So she took me to a little,
um,
a room,
uh,
I laid down,
she pasted all these,
uh,
electrodes on my head,
and then brought this gigantis stroke,
put it above my head,
and then turn this thing on.
And in the next moment there was light.
Like I had never seen.
I couldn't even imagine existed.
My only concept there was a,
this is what it must have been like in Hiroshima,
where the thing went off,
you know,
uh,
today I think it was more like a tea Dharmakaya the,
the primary clear light from Bardo Trudeau from the Tibetan book of the dead
that we see at the moment of our death.
Uh,
but what happened is my consciousness was catapulted out of my body.
I lost,
uh,
the research assistant,
you know,
I lost the clinic,
I lost the Prague I of the planet.
And,
uh,
I had,
the feeling that I actually stepped extinguished,
uh,
in,
in the form that I knew myself,
but also the sense that I somehow became everything there was,
I became all of a,
all of existence.
Uh,
as you know,
we must have heard it quite a few times that these states are considered
ineffable.
It's when you start,
the trying to describe them is you find out that we just simply don't have,
don't have language.
Our language is developed,
you know,
to communicate about things from,
from everyday life.
And in my later experiments,
some of the sophisticated,
uh,
patients actually tried to use a language from cultures that knew something
about consciousness,
like using,
you know,
from,
from induced and from,
uh,
you know,
Tibetan Buddhism from Tao is,
and sort of the,
we're talking about,
uh,
you know,
Nirvikalpa Samadhi,
stomach help us,
nobody can show a Satori,
you know,
using terms like Maya and so on because we simply don't have a technical terms
for,
for the states.
So,
uh,
the experiences of mystical states are full of paradoxes.
Paradoxicality is one of the characteristics,
so you can have the feeling that you became nothing,
but by becoming nothing,
you actually became a of a existence.
Uh,
so I was in this incredible state and then
as she was continuing,
uh,
breaking with me,
it was unfolding.
She had a protocol.
So she started from two Hertz,
which is,
you know,
two frequencies per second,
took it up to 60,
and then she kept it for a while in the Alpha range.
Then the data range,
the Delta range,
and then she turned it off.
And why she was doing this,
that at a certain point,
I actually went from this sense of being everything,
of being in the universe,
in the astronomical universe or,
or actually being the universe.
Uh,
there were things happening for which at the time I didn't have,
uh,
names,
but then later I read about,
uh,
you know,
the,
a big bank and the black holes and the wormholes.
And so this was something in that category and it was happening to me.
I actually had the feeding again that I not,
was not only in the universe,
but I actually was the universe.
And then,
uh,
you know,
as she turned it off,
then my world started shrinking again.
I found the planet.
I found Prague.
I zoomed in on my body,
but there was a major problem because by my consciousness was actually,
uh,
kind of,
circling around my body and I had difficulties aligning.
My consciousness was,
uh,
my body.
So at that point it became clear to me that what,
uh,
they had teaching at a university is about consciousness as a product of the
brain.
Simply was nonsense.
That is,
you know,
consciousness was something cosmic and that the brain somehow is a moderator for
that,
but it's not the generated in,
in our skull.
Could you even find it?
I managed to align death and uh,
I came down in an very ecstatic state,
very impressed with just happened and they were right there.
I decided if I'm a psychiatrist,
uh,
you know,
this is by far the most interesting thing I can do working with these,
with these states,
it's just overshadowed psychoanalysis.
You like,
uh,
you know,
I was not interested in psychoanalysis anymore.
I was interested in exploring the psyche using these states.
So you,
you,
you've at this point dedicated more than six decades to studying non ordinary
states of consciousness,
uh,
which is,
I think we'll probably talk about this.
That is a,
a term or a phrase you prefer over altered states of consciousness.
But,
uh,
you're,
you're alluding to perhaps a definition of consciousness or how you think about
it now.
How do you think about consciousness at this point?
You said that,
uh,
it's,
I think mediated or moderated by the brain,
but not generated by it.
Uh,
based on these experiences,
the experiences of others you've supervised,
everything you've,
you've seen and experienced and studied up to this point,
how do you think about consciousness now?
Are there any other aspects
that you'd like to,
and I'm very close now to every Laszlo who is this brilliant,
uh,
a systems theorist and a philosopher of Hungarian origin,
but living in Pisa in,
in Italy,
and he has a series of books where he essentially addressing these problems.
He's the only one debit,
I think,
found some way of scientifically describing what is happening to us.
And he has a book called what is reality,
but he actually goes through these different that we have related to
consciousness and,
uh,
argues,
you know,
what,
what are the,
um,
uh,
observation that we have against the idea that,
that consciousness is local that is inside of our brain.
And he moves to the,
that just,
this is more transpersonal,
that it,
uh,
in the non ordinary states you can have experiences of consciousness of other
people.
You can have experiences of,
uh,
of being in becoming members of a different species and not just animals,
but also plants and so on.
So he moves from that,
from the consciousness being local to coaches as being transpersonal.
And then he brings even arguments against that and concludes that that
consciousness is costs make.
And you know,
that would be,
that would be my present.
Understanding the consciousness is simply a part of integral part of existence.
It cannot be reduced to two anything as let alone the neurons in the brain.
Uh,
so this also support it.
Now,
of course by many people from quantum relativistic physics and,
um,
for example,
Stuart Hameroff initially thought that maybe it's the called tubules in the mid
200 [inaudible] in the,
in the brain might be the place where some quantum processes generate
consciousness.
And then later he sort of took it back and he says,
now,
uh,
according to him,
consciousness is simply a property of the universe that can be traced back to,
uh,
the big bank in the form of protocol consciousness.
Okay.
There's a term that people often associate of course rightly with you in
association with consciousness and that is holotropic states of consciousness.
And I'd love to,
to jump into that because,
uh,
it also,
just as a side note for people listening who are wondering what the applications
of uh,
these,
uh,
non ordinary states might be or how they've been utilized.
There are men,
if it appears to me that there are many,
many different ways to utilize this.
There's certain multiple Nobel prizes associated with it.
Kary Mollis,
Francis Crick and they code discovery of the double helix.
And then there are uh,
you know,
well known entrepreneurs and so on like Steve Jobs.
But what does whole atropic refer to a hold of topic,
state of consciousness?
He was great.
Great question.
But I have so far been or we have been using the term non ordinary states of
consciousness,
which is better.
That one about psychiatry is British and American psychiatry side doing calling
it altered state.
You know,
I really dislike that term,
although it was coined by a good friend of mine,
uh,
Charlie Tarik.
Um,
because it suggests somehow that there is a correct way of experiencing
ourselves and the world and that's somehow a disturbed,
you know,
I always have to think about veterinary medicine and we talk maybe if we had our
dog altered.
So I'm feel too much respect for these days to call them altered.
And even the state non ordinary,
it's really not accurate because there many non ordinary states that have not
the properties that a,
the holotropic states would have.
So I use the term holotropic four s special,
large subcategory of non ordinary states that have Ealing potential therapeutic
potential that have,
according to my experience,
transformative potential that have,
uh,
what we call your stick Agu are,
which means when you work with these states,
you run into a lot of paradigm breaking,
uh,
observations that challenged the whole way of thinking,
not just in psychiatry but in a terroristic science.
And then I believe they also have evolutionary.
I think they would if people would systematically use them.
Uh,
I,
I think we will almost become another and other species,
you know,
people,
uh,
work through a lot of aggression.
It's replaced by compassion.
They have the experience of,
uh,
tremendous,
ecological sensitivity.
They,
they discovered that we are deeply embedded in nature and that we cannot do
anything to nature that doesn't damage as they start seeing.
Violence is an unacceptable way of,
uh,
of solving problems.
You know,
they have a sense of,
uh,
being actually global citizens,
rather than being Czechs or Russians or Americans,
they start seeing themselves very much the way it happened to the astronauts who
at the possibility of actually seeing the,
the planet,
uh,
from,
the moon or from space.
Uh,
so,
um,
this is my term that I coined because I realized psychiatry does not have that
kind of distinction.
So I coined it myself.
It's a kind of a variable hybrid.
It's a neologism as we call it.
Uh,
that comes from the Greek language.
We're holistic means whole and tread portrait.
Pain means I'm moving in the direction of something.
I usually refer to the,
uh,
Elliot tropism.
Helios means son and heliotropism is the property of plants to always orient
themselves towards the sun always followed the sun.
So literally this means moving toward wholeness.
You know,
when I,
when I use that term,
there's usually somebody who say,
uh,
what do you mean moving toward wholeness?
Aren't we whole already the way we function in everyday life?
And I would have to say no.
On the basis of my,
we have a,
we are using only a small fraction of our experiential potential when we are in
the ordinary states.
So maybe I just give a few examples of,
of all the tropic states of people have a sense of what I'm talking about.
Yes,
please.
So one category when you would find stays that I called holotropic would be the
initiatory crisis of Shamans in the carrier of most Germans begin by a
spontaneous experience of traveling into the visionary experience of traveling
into the universe,
being traveling into the,
the,
um,
underworld,
Ferris,
uh,
they have the experience of being exposed to some,
ordeals,
uh,
experience,
a lot of emotional,
physical pain and they experience Nia Alation and then,
uh,
experience of psycho spiritual death,
rebirth that's followed by this journey into the supernatural realms.
And in this initiatory journey,
they heal themselves.
Typically a anthropologists called chairman's,
the wounded healers,
and they also learn how to heal.
So when they then managed to come back and they ground decision,
they use holotropic states in their healing.
When they heal,
they either go into an unordinary state or the induce them in their clients,
or both Shamans and clients get into this holotropic state.
So that's a major category.
The second one is what you see in a so-called a rites of passage.
This is the term that was coined by a Dutch anthropologists are not one Hennit,
that's g,
who studied many native cultures.
And he found out that they all,
uh,
you know,
at the time of important biological or social transitions,
uh,
perform a very powerful rituals,
when they also induce in the cellar tropic states in,
in different ways,
uh,
many of those cultures,
even with psychedelic plants,
so psychedelic psychedelic materials in some others using,
uh,
you know,
sonic technology,
drumming,
ref,
DirectLink and so on.
A physical pain,
stay in the desert,
stay in the high mountains,
uh,
stay in a cave in the Arctic ice and so on.
And if you study these people experience psycho spiritual death,
rebirth,
very much like the Shamans in the spontaneous,
a initiatory journey.
And of the third important category,
uh,
with the ancient mysteries of death,
rebirth,
like the Eleusinian mysteries or the eyes is society's mysteries in Egypt or the
Sumerian mysteries of Inanna and,
uh,
[inaudible].
And also,
you know,
they were,
they were Mesoamerican,
uh,
mysteries of Shababa,
the Mayan and so on.
Uh,
so,
um,
all of these were inducing these holotropic states for healing and
transformation.
And then also all the major religions developed what I called technologies of
the sacred,
you know,
different forms of Yoga,
uh,
different schools of Buddhism from,
Teravata to,
to,
uh,
then,
and,
uh,
much Rhianna.
Dow is exercises in the Christian tradition,
has see cars and the Jesus prayer or the exercises of Ignatius,
Saint Ignatius of Loyola.
Uh,
it's various cabalistic cabalistic exercises.
So those were all,
um,
methods that were designed to,
to take people into this holotropic experiences,
uh,
for the purpose of,
of having a mystical experience,
having a spiritual experience.
And of course,
we have now modern,
uh,
technology,
so the sacred to induce holotropic experiences.
We have now a pure alkaloids from,
from,
uh,
the psychedelic plants.
You know,
we have,
uh,
mescaline from PR,
we have a seal of sin and silicide being from the magic mushrooms of the,
uh,
the muscle techs,
we have now,
um,
uh,
the,
Ibogaine gain from,
from Alga,
from,
from the African,
um,
African,
a Welsh and so on and to be also have now,
uh,
the tryptamine derivatives,
DMT a DPT,
and then meth,
oxy,
the empty,
those are of active in Ayahuasca and in the different snuffs from the Caribbean.
Um,
and also from this,
uh,
toward,
that's now becoming very famous than,
than before,
before our Larios.
This are secretions from the parotid glands and from the skin of the stores.
Very,
very powerful,
very important.
Uh,
psychedelics.
So let me pause for one second.
I have many,
I'm not going to lose track of the train and I have a number of different
questions.
But since,
since you brought it up,
uh,
a mutual friend of ours,
different mutual friend had had suggested I ask you about toad and you just
mentioned that,
uh,
it,
it could be or is important.
And you mentioned methoxy Dmt,
uh,
which,
you know,
in this case,
uh,
often referred to a five meo DMT.
What are your thoughts on this particular,
this particular compound?
Uh,
and,
and why is it important,
if it's important?
Well,
the thing is,
it has not really been explored scientifically unlike silicide,
you know,
or Lsd.
But we have enormous amount of information from either stem illegal or illegal,
you know,
underground experiments,
which were happening during those years when psychedelics,
uh,
we're not really explored scientifically.
Uh,
but we have an amazing book by,
uh,
Ralph Metzner,
which is called the tote.
And the Jaguar,
uh,
Ralph or traveled all over Europe and in the United States visiting this groups
that were using it,
um,
you know,
either using some legal loopholes or,
or,
uh,
you know,
doing it kind of an underground,
uh,
research.
And he wrote this book where he,
where he collected that information in,
in a way that,
uh,
could become a basis of,
of scientific research.
Now what is fantastic there is a,
that this substance creates a very short,
uh,
you know,
within an hour,
which is in the time of one cycle psychoanalytic session.
You can experience significant,
uh,
transformation,
even,
even spiritual,
uh,
opening.
Uh,
and the,
the substances method.
See The empty I have in my book when the impossible happens,
a chapter which is called the secret of the tote of light.
There are churches in the American southwest that are actually using it as a
sacrament.
It's called Church of the total of a light.
And I took a fairly large doses,
which is not just more than it's usually used.
Uh,
this was my first time when we really didn't know,
I didn't know the dosing and it was estimated 25 milligrams today you would use
like five or 10.
And uh,
this was by far the most powerful psychedelic experience I've ever had and uh,
was in seconds.
You know,
it took me a,
out of my body.
They were known.
There's nothing biographical,
no,
no birth experiences,
no nothing archetype.
I was just facing this,
uh,
incredible.
Um,
I mean,
source of light for the,
for the lack of a better description,
it was like beyond anything I could imagine in terms of the,
the brilliance,
the in Candice sense that it had.
But also since that this,
there was an incredible intelligence,
creative intelligence going beyond any,
uh,
dichotomies.
I couldn't say for demonic or,
or divine,
uh,
you know,
there was just off the scales that I had.
Um,
and then coming down,
uh,
from that experience,
I actually had the feeling I was dying,
but the feeling that I was not from life into dying but from a place beyond
death into dying body.
And then after awhile it became clear that this was not really dying.
It was just the experience of dying.
And for quite a while I was in a situation where I was in absolutely blissful
kind of state and I was having visions of streams of my past life experiences
where I had feeling of,
you know,
dying and being killed and different situations.
Um,
and my body was kind of acting out.
The,
the agony was shaking,
twitching,
uh,
by,
you know,
psychologically,
emotionally.
I was in,
in absolute bliss.
And then coming down for a week,
I was in a state in which I would like to live.
Uh,
we were at the time,
uh,
living at Sln,
we had a deck overlooking the ocean.
And this was the time when I was handwriting my,
my manuscripts and they're giving it to a secretary and then having to edit it.
And I was in that week,
I was doing editing of my manuscript.
People check would do perfectly lying in the sun there.
And then I felt I will take a little break.
I again,
it was in seconds.
I had the feeling it was just a oneness with the,
the,
the whole environment,
wonders with the world.
And then I would open my eyes and I could continue editing.
But then of course,
you know,
the is sort of the consciousness of the industrial civilization came back,
to uh,
do workshops,
travel,
uh,
you know,
so,
um,
I didn't stay in that,
in that state,
but,
uh,
my meditations became a much,
much,
much deeper and it was not difficult to get into some version of that state,
you know,
just through meditation.
So I think this would be an amazing,
amazing substance to try for practical reasons because you've,
you will not find a psychiatrist like myself,
uh,
in the,
um,
you know,
in the 60s and so on,
uh,
sitting for six hours with their patients,
but they could certainly do a one hour session with the methoxy DMT and,
uh,
I think significant,
therapy could be done,
you know,
within these very short,
uh,
short term.
It's also according to Ralph Messiness,
observations,
uh,
it's a,
substance where the experience and very cleanly the,
there is no sort of lingering on.
So there is a very powerful experience,
but also a good,
a good closure.
So,
anyway,
so this is my experience with the metric CD empty now.
It was called,
it's a very,
very popular,
for example,
we had the transpersonal conference in Prog,
you know,
and there were lectures about it and of course they were,
there were people who had access to the,
to,
uh,
the toad material to the excretions or secretions of the glands.
So it's becoming a very,
very popular,
popular substance right now.
You mentioned therapy a few times in describing your experience with five Amino
DMT in the potential,
say within a one hour window or something like that,
uh,
to,
provide,
uh,
therapy if someone were sitting for someone experiencing this.
Uh,
I want to tie that into a comment that you're very famous for having made.
And I think it was in your first book in 1975 realms of the human unconscious in
which you mentioned the Lsd could become for psychiatry,
what the microscope was for biology and,
uh,
in medicine and what the telescope is for astronomy.
Uh,
what I'm curious about is,
I suppose a,
why you say that,
but then B,
is there still a place for psychoanalysis,
you know,
traditional psychoanalysis or psychotherapy in combination with some of these,
uh,
psychedelic compounds?
Uh,
because it,
it's,
it seems to me that the,
uh,
perhaps some of the value that people derive from these experiences or don't
derive from these experiences is dependent quite a bit on what happens
beforehand and what happens afterwards.
But I just,
I just love to hear you.
I suppose clarify what you mean by LSD becoming for a psychiatry with the
microscope is for biology and the telescope is for astronomy and then B,
if therapy still has a place in combination with these.
Another wonderful question.
So let me tell you what happened when I lost interest in this laboratory,
uh,
research and took it to the clinic.
Uh,
uh,
we were,
you mentioned in the,
in your interview with Michael Pollan,
there are these two forms.
Uh,
they'd been using,
uh,
LSD and other secondary,
the psycholytic and the psychedelic.
The psychedelic is the,
you know,
using large dosage is fully internalized with,
uh,
headphones,
eye shades,
and,
uh,
the method that was used mostly in Europe,
but also by some American,
uh,
therapists.
It's called psycholytic,
which is sort of dissolving the psyche,
dissolving the tensions,
conflicts in the psyche and so on,
uh,
from,
from uh,
Lucy's means this solution.
And so I started it with using sort of medium dosages,
may be,
you know,
150,
uh,
maybe up to 200 at the beginning.
And what happened was absolutely fascinating because,
uh,
so intensification of the symptoms that the patients who are having,
but then the process automatically took us to the different layers of a
traumatic experiences that were actually underlying that disorder and layer
after layer.
Then I came up with the concept of a coexistence system of condensed experience
where each symptom had like,
uh,
history,
you know,
has a,
uh,
a series of layered experiences behind it.
Uh,
and so it was a process of exploring the different layers of the psyche.
one of my patients call it a onion peeling of the,
of,
uh,
the psyche.
And other uncoded,
uh,
chemo archeology.
So you could really explore the different layers of the postnatal biographical
level.
This is what,
what,
uh,
Freudian analysis is about.
But the problem is it didn't stop there.
Then each of those,
uh,
coexistence also had a contribution from the trauma of burst.
There's suit,
even if we're using these lower dosages as we were going on,
it took us to birth and that point,
suddenly people started experiencing,
uh,
that they are trapped.
They're caught.
They aren't in a situation of no exit.
Uh,
they had the feeling they're getting crazy,
uh,
you know,
they are dying and so on.
And,
um,
you know,
my psychiatry and my,
uh,
my,
psychotic training did not prepare me for that kind of thing.
And it took,
while,
including my own experiences to realize there was a powerful record of
biological birth in there.
So,
um,
what we activated actually,
uh,
in the psyche was what I call now self healing intelligence of the psyche.
You see,
the,
the process spontaneously was talking.
It was taking us to the sources of,
uh,
of,
these,
uh,
emotional and psychosomatic symptoms.
It also created automatically the mapping of the psyche.
So,
um,
for awhile I was just collecting these,
uh,
um,
reports from the page,
my,
my own records and,
and,
uh,
people's,
um,
you know,
descriptions of their sessions and I was putting it on a map,
creating a,
what I thought was a new map for,
uh,
or psychology,
um,
which would be,
and the result of the fact that we had absolutely new tool like a microscope
open up,
you know,
this whole underworld which we in micro world,
which we didn't know existed.
And telescope discovered new new galaxies that the astronomers didn't know
about.
So,
uh,
you know,
I felt we were discovering,
uh,
the depths of the,
of the psyche.
So in that sense it was like a microscope or a telescope,
but it also was the self healing intelligence that,
that sort of,
uh,
emerged out of it in.
Do you find now when I finally got the map to get,
yeah.
Oh No,
I was just going to say please continue.
I was just going to,
I'm just going to ask about if their adjunct therapies or things that you would
add to the beginning,
the,
the pre psychedelic experience or post psychedelic experience.
But I don't want to interrupt your train of thought.
Well,
I just a couple of sentences.
So the new map which I created,
which I thought was new,
had the biographical level,
which it shared with psychoanalysis and current,
uh,
psychiatry because uh,
you know,
however much Freud was criticized,
psychiatry accepted is uh,
uh,
idea that the newborn is a Tabula Rasa is a clean slate.
There's nothing of interest to a psychologist,
psychiatrist that proceeds bearers.
And this was a major discovery.
There is a powerful,
powerful record of purse.
And,
uh,
when you become of aware of that fact,
you have to radically change,
transform a thinking in,
in psychiatry.
So this new new map or map that I thought was new had the biographical level
that it shared with,
uh,
with,
current psychiatry.
But then I had to add the level of which I called perinatal,
which is related to birth with the record of burst.
And then it opened up further into,
uh,
the level that I call a transpersonal now.
And there's a greater overlap with what young described as the collective
unconscious,
the historical and the,
the,
uh,
archetype archetypal unconscious.
But you see,
when I had the map,
I realized this was not a new map at all.
Like should a map that in different forms,
it's been around for not for four centuries,
but for millennia,
I started seeing the connection to the great spiritual philosophies of the east,
of Hinduism,
Buddhism,
Taoism,
Sufism,
and so on.
And even the shamanic maps,
there was a lot of overlapping with the,
with the Shamanic,
uh,
cartography.
Uh,
so I haven't forgotten your original question was about psychoanalysis.
now the problem is that psychoanalysis has this very narrow map,
limited to postnatal biography into the individual unconscious,
which is,
uh,
just barely scratching the surface of what the psyche really is.
So if you would do psychoanalysis,
you would have to expand the conceptual framework very,
very radically.
Because otherwise,
if you would get to something like perinatal experiences or transpersonal
experiences,
you would not have any map if you use just Freudian,
Freudian psychoanalysis.
So it's not the,
it's not the question of the technique.
I think in my understanding,
Freud was actually in a right on the right track.
He was asking questions like,
why do we have,
uh,
um,
you know,
hysteria,
why do we have,
uh,
phobias?
Why do we have an obsessive compulsive neurosis?
Why do we have perversions and so on?
He was tracing it back,
but unfortunately his map was very superficial.
He did not have access to the,
uh,
to the perinatal level,
to the transpersonal level.
So he ended up with conclusions that then,
uh,
sometimes,
seemed absurd.
You know,
like,
uh,
suicide is killing the interjected a bed breast of your mother and so on.
And then there was a tendency just to move away completely and not ask the
questions about etiology that Freud's genius was trying to understand.
You know,
why do we have a certain kinds of symptoms?
Why do we have anxiety?
Why do we have a depression of why do we have a suicidal tendencies and so on,
and was looking for a rational understanding for this.
But he took it only,
uh,
not even halfway had he had access to the perinatal level.
He would have gotten much more,
uh,
convincing understanding why do we have a depression,
different forms of depression.
Why,
what,
what does it mean when people would want,
uh,
to kill themselves in a way that is nonviolent as compared to people who have
the tendency to commit violence you site and so on.
So if you expand the cartography and you,
you add the perinatal level and the transpersonal level,
you can continue this,
a psychoanalytic work actually and get,
um,
you know,
some reasonable,
quite convincing answers.
Why do we have certain kinds of symptoms?
Why do they cluster in what we call syndrome and so on.
And it also opens up a new radical,
different,
uh,
approaches to psychotherapy,
which would be,
we'd have to be experiential if the roots of,
uh,
emotional problems are not just a postnatal,
but also perinatal and transpersonal.
You cannot reach it by talking.
He would have to actually,
uh,
use experiential,
psychotherapy of the kind that started in the,
in the 60s,
the developed within humanistic humanistic psychology.
Let's,
let's go directly to that.
And,
uh,
I certainly have,
we're going to come back to when the impossible happens.
We're going to come back too many different pieces of your past experience and,
and more recent projects,
but this experiential psychotherapy in,
in,
in an ideal world,
based on all of your experience,
what would that look like?
What would the format look like?
Well,
we are talking about psychedelics.
So one would be psychedelic assisted psychotherapy.
When,
uh,
you know,
people would have sessions and then you would use talking,
uh,
helping them to integrate,
helping them to understand.
So they would be,
you know,
focus on the,
on in the therapy would be on the experience,
but also,
um,
it would be so,
uh,
at the same time,
very much what it was for Freud,
it would be exploration of the psyche,
getting to know the dimensions of the psyche that the different,
uh,
levels of experiences and so on.
Uh,
but now we have powerful a non drug experiences that can actually take you to
those levels,
to the perinatal level,
to the a transpersonal level.
So,
um,
my late wife Christina and I developed a,
what we call holotropic breathwork,
where you use very simple means,
which is a faster breezing,
some powerful,
evocative music,
a certain kind of a body work.
Uh,
and then we also use art.
We use a Mandela drawing and sharing groups and people have access to,
uh,
not just to the postnatal,
a biographical level,
but also to the perinatal and to the transpersonal level.
So there are,
you know,
there are both pharmacologic and nonpharmacologic weights of,
of uh,
uh,
accessing these levels that have the deepest roots of,
emotional psychosomatic problems.
So I'm really glad you brought up holotropic breathwork,
uh,
which is,
as you mentioned,
a non pharmacological or non exogenous way of inducing these holotropic states,
uh,
which,
which I've,
I've experienced three times in different,
uh,
workshops for holotropic breathwork.
And,
uh,
I,
I went into it,
I'm not going to lie to you,
skeptical as someone with psychedelic experience that it could achieve anything
comparable.
And I was really stunned by just how,
uh,
how powerfully you can induce,
these,
these non ordinary states using breath work.
Uh,
and what I observed in other people in the rooms as well,
who many of,
many of which were,
we're skeptical as I was at the time.
So two,
two questions to,
to uh,
dig into both the,
uh,
supposed to be a psychedelic or entheogenic assisted and then the holotropic
breathwork approach.
What,
what psychedelic materials in what dosages would you potentially be using,
uh,
with what frequency would it be once a week,
twice a week?
Would it be determined by the patient?
Would it be psycholytic dosing or would it be psychedelic dosing?
How would you think about that piece of the puzzle?
I wouldn't do psycholytic therapy,
although I very much value the information that I got from it.
You know,
as the self healing intelligence of the psyche,
the coexistence and,
and to discovery of,
uh,
the,
the dimensions that are on that expanded map being taken to,
uh,
to the perinatal level and then to the transpersonal level.
Uh,
I also have a lot of interesting observations.
If you read the ramps of the human unconscious a this,
a lot of it is about,
um,
trying to understand how and why the world is changing under the influence of
Lsd or some other psychedelics.
I became fascinated,
you know,
the people saw me at different periods of their session as a different things.
They saw me as a Jaguar.
They saw me as a toddler.
They saw me as angel,
they saw me as a supreme judge,
uh,
or they look around the treatment room and sometimes the,
the feeling that,
uh,
they are on the death row.
Sometimes Kevin in the Pacific,
a symptom,
sometimes it was a Bordello and so on.
So I did the kind of frothy and work on it,
trying to understand how it condensed,
you know,
different levels of the material.
Uh,
so I got a good understanding of the dynamics of the postnatal biography,
but I also found out that it was not the most effective way of getting therapy,
therapeutic results.
So then,
uh,
already in Prague I increased the dosage,
I started using music and uh,
and the headphones eye shades.
And this is how we did the whole research,
uh,
at Spring Grove,
the American research when I,
when I came to the United States there you can very,
very powerful transformation,
you know,
within there then six,
eight hours of the high dose.
Uh,
but you don't have any idea why that happened.
You don't understand the mechanism of the change.
It resembles the material that journey.
Rosen described when he studied the experiences of people who did suicidal jumps
from a golden gate bridge and,
and,
um,
the bay,
the bay bridge,
he found that people who survive with which is about 1%,
they usually a survival it unscathed and they experience powerful transformation
within the three seconds that it took to get from the fall,
from the railing to the surface of the water,
and then maybe about eight minutes in cold water before they were rescued.
Uh,
um,
again,
powerful,
powerful changes that you know,
you wouldn't achieve by a year or so of psychoanalysis.
But,
uh,
there was no understanding what,
what happened.
Uh,
now with this history of the psycholytic therapy,
I have now some idea about what is happening in these high dose sessions,
but in a very condensed,
very rapid,
rapid way.
So by high dose,
what does that generally mean?
A state once more.
Oh,
by high dose,
how many micrograms would you generally be using?
Okay.
I would probably use now a dosage is like a,
you know,
300 or even 400 to 400 micrograms,
which uh,
you know,
might be in some instances it's not very frequently.
It might be a challenge the management of the,
of the session,
but you generally get much more powerful transformation.
Also cleaner.
Actually if you use smaller dosages,
there is a tendency sometimes to actually activate what happens and people have
more of a chance to,
to resist it if there are areas,
areas that they don't want to go into.
So I consider the high dosages if this proper management to be more effective
therapeutically,
I would use now that smaller dosages if we continue the exploration of the
psyche,
you know,
that's,
that's where lower dosages are.
Sydney very useful.
And I'm very sorry that this is not happening with,
uh,
with psychedelics in this new renaissance.
With that we don't continue the Freudian work where we are trying to,
to go to,
to find what the roots are trying to understand the etiology.
Now in these,
in these later,
uh,
Dsm,
the diagnostic and statistical statistical manual,
uh,
they moved completely from any question of etiology.
You know,
they now just,
uh,
describe the,
the symptoms.
They use,
what they call neoprep alien,
uh,
approach.
Uh,
Mel crap.
Berlin was the,
uh,
the person who did the first diagnosis in a,
in a psychiatry at the turn of the 19th and 20th century.
Um,
dementia,
pray Cox,
which was the original name for schizophrenia and manic depressive disorder.
Those were the,
the first two diagnosis in psychiatry and what he did,
he just simply described the symptoms that these patients have.
And now the tendency in psychiatry is to go to the neoprep alien.
Like in the DSM.
You don't ask the question of why do we have a depression?
Why do we have suicidal tendencies?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
why do you have different psychosomatic disorders?
It's just simply describing the symptoms.
And I think there is tremendous field of discovery which would be doing
individual cases.
Like initially in psychoanalysis,
you had,
uh,
I think about 1500 psychoanalysts all over the world who were seeing their
patients.
And they were,
they were describing what they observed and it was published in journals and so
on until they ended up with the psychoanalytic understanding of,
uh,
emotional psychosomatic disorders.
Do you find in AutoFair Nichols book,
the psychoanalytic theory of a neurosis?
Uh,
um,
so we need,
we need to continue that kind of work.
This would be something for psychoanalysts to do,
you know,
to continue Freud's exploration of the psyche,
trying to understand the psyche,
understand why we have symptoms and syndromes.
Uh,
but not keeping it just on the,
uh,
on,
um,
the postnatal level in the etiology.
I think that was the word that I heard earlier is that the exploration of the Y
we experienced closers.
Yes.
Causes,
why do we have that?
So Freud,
Freud had the concept of the development of the libido,
the oral phase when,
uh,
the sensual feelings that are associated with nursing and the of the,
the passive oral,
and then the active oral when,
uh,
um,
the,
the infant starts biting his teeth and so on.
And then it moved to the anal phase at the time to have toilet training.
And then refined toilet training,
which had to do with urination.
That was the urethra station.
Then he talked about the phallic stage,
which was the stage where the focus is on the,
on the genitals and the clitoris in girls and the penis of the boys.
And then where you have the [inaudible],
uh,
complex and you know,
the castration complex and all those things.
Um,
which was very,
very interesting way of thinking,
but it didn't go deep enough.
So,
uh,
you,
you ended up with very unconvincing interpretations.
But,
uh,
no,
I have tried in my books to,
uh,
continue and see how you would understand,
in a much deeper way.
Why would we have these things?
Do we have depression,
different types of depression,
suicidal tendencies?
You know,
why do we have symptoms like a headache and,
and many,
many a neurotic patients have problems breathing and so on.
Where does that come from?
Why do we end up with psychosomatic paints for which there is no,
uh,
organic a finding?
So if you expand the cartography,
you can really get a much fuller understanding.
You know,
Freud,
at a certain point when he discovered the individual unconscious,
he compared the psyche to an iceberg.
He said what we thought the psyche was is just a surface,
like the part of the iceberg that's showing above the surface.
And psychoanalysis shows you,
uh,
also the submerged a part of the iceberg.
Now,
if you now bring psychedelics,
you have to change the,
the simile or the metaphor,
you would have to say what classical psychoanalysis discovered.
It's just barely the surface is the part of the iceberg that's showing a four
psycho analyst.
And there is an enormous part of the psyche that remained hidden even for,
for a traditional psychoanalysis.
So let me ask you this.
If Joseph Campbell,
I just,
let me just find sentence,
which I cannot resist.
Joseph Campbell and you know,
the wonderful mythologies that is this incredible Irish humor.
He put it differently.
He said Freud was fishing while it's sitting on a whale.
Uh,
the,
you've,
you have seen so many things,
experienced so many things.
Uh,
let's just call it roughly 4,000,
500 different sessions.
You've thought of all these different modalities.
Uh,
looking at my very,
very limited personal experience and what I've observed in other people,
I've,
I've certainly seen as you have some incredible examples of transformation,
people who have seemingly resolved,
uh,
chronic depression or anxiety disorders,
eating disorders,
uh,
and,
and experienced incredible healing,
that that seems to have a persistent effect after experiencing,
uh,
these,
these deep psychedelic states.
I've also observed,
uh,
not a small number of people who collect interesting drug experiences or
psychedelic experiences,
but don't seem to experience or resolve any deeper healing.
What do you think separates those,
those two groups and how,
how can you increase the likelihood of real healing,
real deep healing occurring?
Well,
extremely significant.
Uh,
is the concept of set and setting that means who gives it to whom,
uh,
under what circumstances?
For what purpose,
you know,
that makes a big difference.
I have seen people who have taken LSD hundred times and they didn't discover
that it had something to do with their own psyche.
It was like going to the movies.
They kept their eyes open and you know,
things were floating around check.
People were making funny faces,
like a curious kind of interesting experience,
but had no idea that the way they perceive the environment is actually a result
of the projection from their own unconscious.
So the one major difference is do you keep your eyes open and walk around,
let alone driving cars,
what people have been doing and so on.
Uh,
you know,
or doing it in the raves where,
uh,
it's an open place where,
people don't know what they are taking and,
uh,
the police might,
they,
they know they do something forbidden.
Police might show this is the worst possible set settings.
So you increased tremendously the risk of uh,
these,
uh,
experiences.
Any Regis,
they reduce the potential.
Uh,
so that's,
that's important.
Uh,
so if you come,
if you come with an intention,
the self exploration eeling for me,
for my first LSD session,
it became a spiritual quest.
Every,
every one of my,
uh,
experiences.
Uh,
I had about maybe,
you know,
140 I those psychedelic sessions over the years.
It might seem like a lot,
but it's expanded over,
extended over a period of 60,
60 years.
So if you look at it that much,
it's not that much.
Uh,
so,
uh,
that is extremely,
extremely important.
But what is your intention?
Do you,
is serious intention for self exploration,
self healing?
Is it part of your spiritual quest or,
I are you doing it for,
for cakes?
You know,
because it's sort of a funny,
weird,
a weird experience.
Uh,
there's also,
uh,
something that Euston Smith's set,
which was very interesting.
Uh,
there was this whole discussion about instant on or chemical,
uh,
mysticism when we saw in the early LSD sessions that people had mystical
experiences.
Then this whole question of a chemical mysticism and Kramer,
what is it?
What are we launching?
And there was one,
a group of people who was a,
where sort of hardcore,
uh,
materialistic scientists who says,
well,
here you have it.
What the mystics are some kind of deep,
uh,
insights into ontology.
And cosmology is nothing else but a aberrations of body chemistry.
So,
so much for uh,
mysticism flow much for spirituality.
It's all chemistry.
And there was another group that was saying,
uh,
no,
what is happening?
There is a very special group of chemicals that can induce mystical experiences.
Those are sacred substances,
those are sacraments,
those are sacred medicines and so on.
So they took basically the position that the Shamans of native cultures took who
were using psychedelic plants,
like your tone on our cattle,
you know,
the flesh of the gods and so on the plants either where the it is.
So they had the mediated access to two deities and uh,
uh,
there was this,
position also.
Uh,
the third position was the mystical experiences in use by psychedelics are
phenomenologically indistinguishable from those that are described in spiritual
literature,
but they don't have the same value to have really variable mystical experience.
It has to be a result of,
of prayers,
of meditation or it has to come as a grace.
There's no way you can take a pill and experience God.
So people like Mayor Ababa and so on,
the,
you know,
very,
very negative.
A guy called Zia in,
in,
uh,
a British,
British,
uh,
Sarah login and so on.
Uh,
so this would put it sort of in the,
in the court,
uh,
of a spiritual teachers to say are these variable or not.
And there was disagreement.
All the Tibetans for example,
that I have known and,
and actually being in,
uh,
around some of them when they had sessions,
they all valued it very much as something that that is,
uh,
accelerating your spiritual,
spiritual development.
But just caution that this is very,
this is very powerful that you said to be done very,
very,
uh,
carefully.
Uh,
on the other hand,
Zen Buddhist usually had difficult experiences with psychedelics because you are
not supposed to pay attention to what's happening.
It's called [inaudible].
If you just stop your past life experiences,
you're supposed to sit through it and cut into the no mind place.
It's very difficult to have 300 micrograms and to pay attention to what is,
you just cut through it,
you know,
uh,
no mind place.
And then this is the,
and back now to use and Smith [inaudible] Smith set of people,
unlike a [inaudible] Baba,
uh,
all center,
they had actually experiences,
uh,
he came to us,
to,
um,
uh,
Baltimore,
you know,
for a session.
We had the,
the possibility of giving sessions that legally to,
uh,
people who were ministers during pastoral account counseling and so on.
Uh,
I actually was in one of his,
one of his sessions.
So he knew what he was talking about and he said,
the,
uh,
chemical in use mystical experiences are phenomenologically indistinguishable.
This was already shown in,
uh,
Pankey's Good Friday experiment,
in the Marsh Chapel,
the,
uh,
Boston University.
Very famous experiment,
Good Friday experiment that you'd be,
I know you talked about in your discussion with Michael Poland and so on.
And just to define very quickly,
I apologize for people who are listening for a phenomenal,
phenomenal,
logical or phenomenology.
That's the subjective report.
Yeah.
This,
if you look at the subjective experiences of,
uh,
people who had them through Lsd or Psilocybin,
and you compare it with what you,
what you read about in spiritual literature.
So that's phenom analogically indistinguishable,
but he said,
but the value would be very different depending on the set and that setting.
He said,
if a,
let's say you have a situation,
there is a party in Berkeley and the way it was done and there would be a fruit
punch and the joker comes with a handful of sugar cubes laced with LSD.
People think that drinking punch and then you know this,
they out of their gourds,
there's nobody who's holding the kite string.
And so on.
Even under these lousy circumstances,
sometimes it can happen that people would have mystical experiences,
but it would be completely out of context.
They would not know what to do with difficulties,
uh,
to,
to integrate it and become a kind of very likely alien enclave in their,
in their life.
If it is somebody who is a spiritual seeker who reads literature,
who is doing systematic meditation,
and then now here is that this could accelerate and even do,
um,
the sessions,
you know,
in a proper set and setting the context.
Um,
so in some kind of a reverential attitude and who do then afterwards,
after the sessions,
some,
some reading and continue working on it in meditation,
this could become a really a powerful catalyst of a spiritual journey.
And I think that's a,
that's the correct answer.
You know.
So you've mentioned,
uh,
seekers and a number of names.
A,
a friend of mine recommended,
I don't even know this name and,
um,
maybe a shame that I don't,
but,
uh,
recommended that I asked You about your experiences with Swami Muktananda and I
don't recognize that name,
but I thought that this is as good a time as any to perhaps bring it up.
Uh,
if you,
if you can answer that.
Yes.
It became kind of bite important figure in,
in our lives.
Uh,
I met him first about 1965 when he was on his second tour around the world.
He was the head of the,
of the CD Yoga,
uh,
movement,
um,
the,
during the first trip around the world.
He was actually accompanied by Ram Dass and by,
um,
uh,
by Vernor Earhart.
And,
uh,
again,
my,
uh,
late wife,
Christine,
she came to one of his early session,
he came to Oh,
Lulu.
And she became a devotee of his.
And so when we,
when we connected,
she wanted me to meet Muktananda and arrange this,
uh,
this Darshawn with him in,
in Oakland.
And I described this experience in some later experience,
again,
in a couple of chapters in the book when the impossible happens.
And it was very interesting.
I was very reluctant,
you know,
to go,
I was not a group person.
I would was not sort of somebody who would be,
you know,
at the feet of somebody.
I said,
the feeling that ultimately it was between me and the,
uh,
the cosmos and so on.
Uh,
but,
uh,
we had about 20 minutes waiting for,
for the Darshawn.
And at that point she told me that he was,
eh,
Eh,
shaivite.
Um,
it's used for,
you know,
a follower of Shiva.
And I had of my most powerful
experiences in my sessions with the,
the archetype of,
of Shiva sort of various ways.
And,
uh,
this sort of changed my feeling about this.
It would be interesting find somebody I knew that [inaudible] are using all
kinds of means,
including Bonk,
you know,
hashish and so on and,
and,
uh,
also,
dot.
Torah.
So they have,
it's a very highly experiential,
uh,
group.
And so this change in my attitude to this,
uh,
for this,
interview.
And,
uh,
I walked in and he,
he was sitting there,
you know,
was the,
uh,
red ski cap was dark glasses holding a,
when the wound of a peacock feathers,
sent it with the center oil.
And,
uh,
as I told Longhi,
which just looked like a knight knight shirt and he sort of a back in me,
you know,
to come and you sit here in the chair just by him.
And,
uh,
he turned my head.
And,
uh,
what sort of took off his,
took,
uh,
or,
or sort of shifted up is a dark glasses,
which he very seldom did.
And he sort of looked into my eyes like he was an ophthalmologist,
you know.
And the first thing that he said is,
you're a man who has seen Shiva.
He says,
this is very good and this just blew my mind.
I just finished,
you know,
describing my experiences with,
with Shiva and the fact that this was a very important figure.
And the first thing that he says,
you know,
I can tell you,
I've seen Sheila.
And so we had,
we had this long interview where I actually ask him about the Soma.
Dji was fascinated by,
this is the,
uh,
this,
psychedelic plan that was used to,
you know,
in ancient India.
And it was described in the rig.
Veda hundred over a hundred dancers in regretted are dedicated to Soma.
It was a plant and they were so beverage that was a produced.
And some of the descriptions show that those were to sweat.
Powerful psychedelic,
you know,
half of us is on earth,
half of us in heaven,
we have taken Soma.
Uh,
so we knew that there was a powerful psychedelic,
but the secret was lost.
And so I ask him,
he said,
Oh yeah,
well,
you know,
on my birthday,
uh,
the vedic priests come down to [inaudible] Puri and they do so much ceremony.
You can come as my gift,
I guess,
you know,
uh,
I will introduce you.
And then he died before we could actually do it.
So,
to make a long story short,
then we were walking out of this his room and it was standing at the door and he
looked at us and says,
uh,
you come to,
um,
our intensives,
we have two intense
intensives of cash on Kashmir Shaivism,
uh,
which is,
this kind of,
uh,
um,
Mahajana,
uh,
branch of Buddhism,
that,
uh,
started in Kashmir when in the eighth century,
a rush.
She had a vision of a summer rocks near Srinagar and he went there and,
uh,
exposed some,
cover,
uh,
vegetable cover and they were,
inscriptions carved in the rock that became then the Shiva Sutras.
This was like the Bible of,
of Kashmir Shaivism.
So he said,
come,
this is on Kashmir Shaivism.
He looked at me and says,
this will be very important,
very interesting for you.
And so of course we did.
And when I listened to the Swami,
who started describing what the Kashmir Shaivism,
uh,
was,
I had the feeling that he was stealing,
uh,
you know,
sentences and paragraphs from,
uh,
an article which I had written,
I think 1969,
which was called a secretary ontology and cosmology observations from LSD
sessions.
So the interesting question about,
you know,
what is the common denominator between experiences that people have with LSD,
this strange substance that Swisscom is discovered in,
in Switzerland,
and something that was found written,
uh,
on the,
on the Rock in Srinagar in the eighth century.
And so then we started sort of going to
these intensives whenever we were,
we are need to Muktananda.
And then we actually did a large transpersonal conference,
uh,
in,
um,
Bombay or Mumbai.
Um,
so it's 1982,
which was on ancient wisdom and modern science,
bringing together spiritual teachers and people from the new paradigm circles,
like for each of Fritjof,
capra and you know,
others.
So,
uh,
that was our,
that was our history where we've mentioned,
we've mentioned the title,
you know,
when the impossible happens a few times.
I figured we might as well jump into it and uh,
discuss certainly the,
perhaps the reasons for writing the book,
but also some of the stories I would imagine.
Well,
I would love to hear some of the stories and I would imagine people listening
would love to hear some of the stories as well.
Well,
Tim,
what happened to us that our house in the Middle Valley burn down in,
uh,
in 2001.
And I lost my whole a referential library.
So it was difficult to write books like I used to wear,
you have to refer to people's work and take passages of it and so on.
And so I decided to write a biography,
but you know,
my life has been pretty,
pretty intense,
pretty
rich.
So the question was,
you know,
what do I select?
And then I decided to select observations and experiences from my life that,
uh,
current materialistic science would consider it to be impossible.
This,
this is not,
not possible if the materialistic paradigm is,
is accurate.
So I selected them.
So it's a selected of selection of these stories.
And about one third of this is a dedicated to amazing synchronicities that I
have a experience in my,
uh,
in my life.
And some of the synchronicities were actually related to a Muktananda.
So there are two chapters of it describing what happened between us and,
and uh,
Muktananda what is a synchronicity?
Well,
synchronicity is something that a Carl Gustaf young brought into the,
to the attention of a Western scientists after hesitating for 20 years
collecting for 20 years,
uh,
observations,
because you realize this is a,
uh,
against this is undermining the cornerstone of materialistic science where,
the basic principle is linear causality.
You know,
the,
what we experience is a chain of a linear causality.
Everything that happens as a course and has an as an effect,
and this works in Western materialistic science with the exception of,
uh,
the,
the costs of causes.
You know,
what,
uh,
caused the beginning of the university are we,
we don't go there very frequently because we don't have any,
any good answers for that.
Uh,
now what he showed up,
that there are situations where,
uh,
there's a meaningful correlation or connection between something that's an
interest psychic event,
like a,
like a dream or a vision or a psychedelic experience and something that happens
in material,
the universe,
in the material universe or what we call so called objective reality,
consensus,
uh,
reality.
And now this should not be happening.
I mean,
our psyche should be reflecting the material universe,
which is out there.
It should not get into a kind of playful interaction with it.
Okay.
So let me,
let me just give you a couple of major examples from,
from,
from that book.
Uh,
I,
I'm referring to the experience that I had with Joseph Campbell again,
you know,
great,
great.
Uh,
uh,
mythologist greatest mythologist over the 20th century,
probably of,
of all time.
And he used to come regularly to SLN and do workshop and he went to our workshop
months launch where substance,
so on.
And we were doing some workshops with him.
And in one of these,
uh,
workshops,
he started,
he was talking about young,
he was,
you know,
great supporter and,
and,
and a very enthusiastic about,
uh,
about a young,
and he mentioned synchronicity and somebody didn't understand it and say,
Joe,
could you explain what synchronicity is?
And,
uh,
he first gave this official definition of Young's,
you know,
this is a meaningful connection across time or space,
uh,
between an inter psychic event and something that happened in the material
world.
But he says,
I will give you an example.
He said,
you know,
we were living in downtown Manhattan on the 14th floor of a high rise building.
And my office had two sets of windows.
One was overlooking six avenue,
which was,
you know,
not nothing interesting,
like many streets in Manhattan about the other set was overlooking the Hudson
River.
And there was a beautiful view.
So these two windows were open all the time.
The others,
we were open just for cleaning.
Nobody was bothered to open those windows.
And then he said,
and uh,
at the time I was working on,
uh,
the first volume of what was supposed to be a world mythology and it's called
the way of the animal powers.
And that first volume is about shamanic mythologies of the world.
And then Joe said that I was working on the chapter about Kalahari Bushmen,
the Bushmen,
you know,
living in the Kalahari desert.
And he said that in their mythology,
a major,
a heroic figure is praying mantis.
And so I,
my desk was covered with papers and pictures,
uh,
related to the mentees and the,
the Kalahari bushmen.
And there was Lauren Vander posts,
a book about his childhood when he hit a Bushman nanny.
And it was,
he,
the Lauren under post described how this nanny was seem to be communicating with
the,
with the praying mantis that they were having sort of conversations.
And uh,
you know,
when the,
with the movements,
the,
uh,
the praying mantis seem to be responding to him,
but to her and then sits in the middle of this a work,
I suddenly had this totally irrational impulse to go and open.
One of the windows that we never open and I stick,
stuck my head out and turn it,
uh,
automatically,
to the side.
And they're on the 14th floor of a high rise building on Manhattan.
There was a great specimen of a praying mantis sort of climbing up the,
uh,
the,
building and turned,
uh,
her,
his head toward,
uh,
Joe.
And you said,
uh,
I took a close look and the way a vendor post described it was to it,
there was something,
uh,
that make the prep fragment is looked like a Bushman.
So anyways,
so that's the,
that's historic.
And so,
you know,
it's possible to imagine that somehow praying mentees got into Manhattan,
somebody has it as a pet or whatever and it got to that place.
So,
but that in itself is not very probable happening,
but the fact that it's happened,
you know,
uh,
in such a way that at the time when chose had,
was filled with thoughts about praying mantis and so on,
and he had this irrational impulse to go and open the window that he never
opened and he looks out and you know,
there is a right,
there is a praying mantis and actually turns toward him and gives him a meat.
Got what he felt was meaningful.
Look,
that's pretty mind blowing synchronicity.
So,
you know,
uh,
young hesitated 20 years before he presented it at 1951 in,
in one of the era knows conferences.
And it was presented together with a talk by Wolfgang Pauli,
one of the founders of quantum physics who was,
uh,
first,
um,
Young's patient and then a very close,
very close,
uh,
friend that,
let me just to quickly give you another example,
which is the most mind blowing a synchronicity from,
uh,
my life has please at.
This happened during our first trip to China where we were bringing
transpersonal psychology and,
uh,
holotropic breathwork to China.
And we did a workshop and broad topic breathwork workshop in Janeane,
which is the birth place of,
uh,
of Confucius.
And,
uh,
we were having dinner and one of the participants,
came to me and said,
Stan,
I had an experience about you,
uh,
in my dream last night.
And,
uh,
um,
I said,
what was it?
And,
uh,
she said,
it was my great grandmother who showed up and told me that we have an important
stone in our family for generations,
and that's a stone should go to doctor gruff.
So she actually brought it,
she was holding a beautiful,
beautiful blue velvet bag and opened it.
And it was a fossil,
a nautilus,
the ammonite,
you know,
which are the,
that are the ancestors of,
of,
uh,
the Nautilus.
Very,
very beautiful for sale.
Now,
the interesting thing was that it was picked up at the top of Mount Everest.
I didn't know at that time that it's possible that this is a marine.
Mollusk you see,
so it comes from the bottom of the ocean and it's some,
it got,
uh,
during the creation of Mri,
got to the top of Mount Everest.
Now,
what is interesting about this that,
uh,
when,
I started a transpersonal psychology international association of transpersonal
psychology and the series of international conferences,
we were thinking what would be the proper logo for,
uh,
the international transpersonal association.
And we came up with the,
with the chamber to Nautilus,
you know,
which is a beautiful piece of sacred geometry.
So for decades,
we were using it on the stationary.
It was on all the programs of a transpersonal psychology.
So,
uh,
you know,
here we are bringing transpersonal psychology to China.
And a great grandmother,
uh,
shows up in the dream of a woman who actually was called main,
which is the Chinese name for dream,
and tells her to bring me this,
uh,
this sale nautilus uni,
which was taken from the bottom of the ocean to the top of the,
uh,
of,
the highest mountain in the world.
Uh,
according to the estimates,
uh,
mls were born about,
about 50 million years ago during the collision of the,
of the tectonic plates.
So this was,
you know,
at least 50 million years old,
uh,
fossil nautilus euro symbol of the international transpersonal association.
So of course the Chinese press,
you know,
didn't describe how great that Holotropic breathwork was,
but they all focused on this incredible synchronicity,
you know.
Are there,
are there any,
uh,
other,
stories or phenomena,
experiences that are difficult to explain in that book are outside of one of the
impossible happens that are related to a psychedelic sessions?
Well,
there are of course,
experiences of the,
um,
a out of body experience.
It's in near death experiences.
You know,
where people who are in a state of,
uh,
clinical death,
cardiac death,
or even a flat,
uh,
EEG have experiences.
They might be watching the,
the procedure from,
uh,
from the ceiling.
Uh,
uh,
so that when they brought back to consciousness,
they are able to describe the procedure.
There's one case where this was happening to a woman who had to be frozen
because they needed to get to the tumor at the base of the skull.
And so she had fled,
uh,
electrocardiogram fled,
electric answer,
fellow Graham.
And at the same time,
this is the most detailed description of the,
uh,
of the surgical procedure that we have or she was able to,
to draw the instruments that they were using and so on.
So there are many,
many of these.
And,
uh,
we had,
we had a couple of those experiences with our own,
uh,
cancer patients.
So there's one of them is described in the book.
Uh,
uh,
there is,
um,
there is one chapter which I called,
uh,
Unorthodox psychiatry where people experience healing in connection with the
experiences that you know,
wouldn't make any,
any sense to current psychiatrists.
What,
what would be an example of that?
So there was one situation where we had a five day
workshop at SLN and a woman came who had four,
two last two years,
had had a very bad depression,
which a psychiatrist would consider to be what's called a endogenous,
which of course doesn't mean anything and endogenous means generated from
within.
Um,
but the characteristic is that it's worse in the morning.
So she got out of the bed and it took her like a couple hours before she managed
to brush her teeth and,
and,
uh,
you know,
get dressed properly and so on.
So she had,
uh,
um,
two sessions,
uh,
with us,
which we had in the five days at SLN.
And,
uh,
you know,
they were pretty powerful things from childhood and she was,
uh,
reliving her birth.
But a Friday in the morning,
which was the last day she came and she,
uh,
actually experience some intensification of these feelings.
So we,
uh,
ask her to lie down.
We had a different,
different program for that more naked or the conclusion of the five days,
but it was clear that we had to do something.
So she laid down in the,
in the middle of the room and,
uh,
we just told her just to go with the experiences is she didn't even do more
breathing.
And she again,
uh,
completed a little something,
but the,
um,
experience of,
uh,
the birth biological births and then went to,
went into this very strange,
uh,
serious of movements where does look like sort of,
praying or worshiping something end up in a,
in a sitting position.
And then this monotonous chant,
repetitive chant,
came,
uh,
in a language that,
that we did not understand.
And this was going for quite a while.
And then it ended and she,
uh,
laid back and she was just completely blissed out,
you know,
in a,
in an aesthetic state.
Uh,
the group was reacting in a strange way.
People were ending up in their lotis positions.
Um,
you know,
uh,
some of them crying for unknown reasons.
And we had a Jewish,
a psycho analyst from a bonus IRS participating in this,
uh,
typically a five day workshop.
And he came to us and he said,
this is fantastic.
Do you understand what happened?
We said No.
Uh,
he said she was,
she was a chanting and perfect Sephardic language,
the Ladino,
which is the medieval mixture of,
of,
uh,
Spanish and Hebrew.
And it happened to be his hobby.
You know,
he will,
he knew the Sephardic a language and we say,
wow,
it's just,
we ask him what,
what was she singing?
This is what she was singing.
I am suffering and I will always suffer.
I am crying and I will always cry.
I am praying and I will always pray.
Now,
this episode finished this two years of the exogenous depression we saw her than
couple of times at conferences and the depression never came back to back.
So the idea of,
you know,
healing,
Eh,
depressions,
pretty bad depression by singing a Sephardic prayer.
It's,
it's a pretty unusual sort of a therapeutic,
uh,
mechanism.
What do you,
what do you make of that?
how do you,
I have learned that,
you know,
self,
we,
we seen a lot of this kind of thing,
the B that a healing happens,
powerful hearing happens in the holotropic breathwork through mechanisms that we
don't understand.
Uh,
I saw before,
you know,
working with people who were in psychoanalysis.
So on the opposite that people,
uh,
after years of psychoanalysis,
they got to the point where they can give you lectures,
why they have the problems,
how is it related to early cannibalism and the,
you know,
the toilet training and her deepest problems.
Only the problems don't change very much.
So you are,
you have the option to either have a very little result with what seems to be
intellectual understanding or a result where you have no clue what.
And in that particular experience with these Sephardic chanting that was with,
that was following breath work,
but not using any type of dosing of an all type of Ontario.
No,
we were,
you were careful not to bring in people,
not to bring anything into the,
you know,
the uh,
holotropic breathwork sessions.
Uh,
because it's the,
the structure is completely different.
The,
the timing of the breathwork is different about three hours and the type of
music that we use.
So it would not be,
it would not be great set and setting.
It's not,
it's not structured for a psychedelic experience.
And actually this would,
uh,
you know,
disturb.
We had one situation,
actually there's somebody who had a black belt,
uh,
took it going into our,
our workshop at Sln,
uh,
without telling us and ended up,
you know,
when a pretty aggressive situation and uh,
it's just a very disturbed the whole,
the whole session.
We had a hard time sort of,
um,
you know,
bringing him,
bringing him down.
Sounds terrifying.
You've just been in metro of principle,
you know,
it was not only was it illegal,
but it,
it just does not,
does not work well in that context that's created for all atropic breasts.
If,
if you had to an answer the question and there might not be an answer to this or
there might not be an affirmative answer
to the question that someone posed to me,
which was they hadn't experienced holotropic breathwork and they ask,
but they did have a lot of,
uh,
sort of research experiment,
a experience with psychedelics and they asked what psychedelic at what dose is
most similar to the effects or the experience of holotropic breathwork.
It would be more a,
something in the category of Mdm,
a in that,
uh,
the holotropic breathwork can create visions,
you know,
visual experiences,
but it's not that common as it is in,
in,
uh,
LSD or mescaline where you have kind of have,
you know,
read this fantastic fractal display.
So if a colorful images and so on and the whole session could be,
could be very,
very visual in the breathwork is more like an Mtma,
whether you have something that's a almost like on a,
uh,
the interface between vision and a vivid thought and so on.
Uh,
and if,
uh,
if we were to look at another,
subjective experience that's reported with,
with decent regularity,
with psychedelics,
specifically entity encounters.
And this seems to be frequently reported with say,
Iowasca or smokes,
eight saved once more,
uh,
entity and counters and countering entities that well used to be separate from
themselves,
seems to be quite common with Iowasca or smoked DMT.
Nn DMT specifically.
Uh,
what is,
have you seen this in breathwork?
And also why do you make any attempt to interpret what these things mean?
Or is it really left to the person experiencing it to integrate it or to heal
through such,
uh,
a perceived encounter or something that exists independently?
Uh,
uh,
well this,
you know,
this was described of course with,
uh,
with,
payor tear,
the Mescalito Miss Garlia then also very common with Iowasca Pachamama,
the mother,
mother.
Uh,
and so on.
The only time I had it was in an Ios concession,
uh,
where there was a sense of,
actually it's not true.
I had it once in a,
in an LSD early LSD session where there was a presence,
there was a,
um,
energetic presence.
I didn't see,
you know,
a figure,
but there was also communication,
which was a telepathic,
which was without words.
Uh,
this was very strange because,
uh,
this was at a time when we had closed boundaries.
We,
we couldn't even,
uh,
initiative Trevor to Russia,
let alone two to the west.
And there was this kind of entity appearing in my LSD session.
It was like a genie,
almost like asking,
you know,
uh,
what would you like,
your,
your life to be like?
And I said,
I would like to see the world.
I would like to understand a psychosis.
This was the place I was in,
and I would like to have a job that's not the kind of a nine to five job.
I would like to have some kind of a freedom.
And the answer was,
okay,
but your task is to bring spirituality to eastern Europe and to Russia.
I said,
no,
I really did it.
You should know.
I'm flipping out.
I got to know I can't even travel to Poland.
Uh,
and this is promising me.
I can see the world.
But then of course,
it,
it happened,
you know,
then,
uh,
developing transpersonal psychology and become very,
very popular,
um,
in,
in Russia.
And then 25 years ago,
bringing transpersonal psychology too to Czechoslovakia actually.
So,
so that was a fascinating synchronicity again.
Uh,
and then I had one in the IOWASCA session,
but also this was a,
this was a very,
uh,
intense,
but it was guiding my session was,
was sort of telling me what I should look,
look at how I should handle it.
And that's not something that you observe in,
in breathwork very often.
No.
Yeah,
no.
You know,
I actually wrote initially I wrote that I considered psychedelics to be a
nonspecific amplifiers.
Yes.
When I,
and,
uh,
it would have to be modified.
I actually all psychedelics can take you to the areas which I described in that
cartography.
You can experience something from,
from a child's a sufficiently important emotionally.
You can relieve your birth,
you can have prenatal experiences.
Even this is a,
I almost hesitate to say that the reliving your a conception,
you know,
identifying with it on a cellular level with the sperm and the,
and the ovum.
Uh,
you can have past life experiences.
You can have archetypal experiences.
You can,
it can take you to that,
to the collective unconscious and so on.
So the cartography applies to all of them,
but there is a different style in which it's coming.
Uh,
you know,
let's talk about more,
more visuals,
visual and so on.
More emphasis on,
on physical feelings or on the emotions in the certainly,
uh,
Mtma or some,
some of the other NTO they are shifted whole spectrum towards the positive.
There are very few people who have bad trips or Mgma.
Mgma is very dangerous physiologically,
but very,
very easy for most people to,
to handle psychologically,
emotionally.
Uh,
but then I discovered this,
uh,
these,
element in Iowa that there is very frequently the imagery of the Amazonian
jungle or the Anaconda snake is coming.
They kind of,
uh,
a rotor rooter,
you know,
cleansing Jaguars,
images of Jaguar.
So there is some kind of a cell activity.
What from the collective unconscious is actually prevalent in,
in those sessions.
Do you have any opinion or opinion of or experience with microdosing of
different psychedelics?
Is that something you've administered to people or,
uh,
I'd love to hear your thoughts on it.
It's become a topic to guy.
I had had quite,
quite a few,
like the 25 micrograms,
you know,
for,
for hiking or swimming in the ocean or something.
They just enhancement of the,
of the,
um,
perceptual experience of the world.
Uh,
but I haven't experimented with the,
with the smart,
I had lots of very interesting experiences,
uh,
inside of the sessions.
And then particularly coming down from the sessions when I was in a kind of a
state that would,
that you might be experiencing another lower dosages,
but it was at the end of a high dose session rather than,
uh,
an experience per se.
What did you experience at the tail end of those sessions?
What were they,
yeah,
what,
what were,
what were those experiences at the tail end of those high dose sessions that,
uh,
that were interesting?
Well,
you know,
all kinds of psychological insights and a lot of the things that I've been
writing about,
you know,
there are combinations of what I saw in the patients and then getting insights
and understanding,
uh,
even in the,
in the high dose s about pirates of the sessions when I hit some difficult
places,
like for example,
existential despair feeling,
you know,
there's no meaning in life,
absurdity of life and so on,
which,
uh,
very frequently happens in,
during the reliving of births.
When you get to what I call the second a perinatal Matrix,
which is the stage of birth where the uterus contracts,
but there is no opening,
the cervix is not open.
So you have the feeling of,
of total existential despair.
Total bummer.
There's no,
I don't mean like everything's absurd.
We go from nowhere to nowhere.
Uh,
uh,
we come to this world naked crying in pain,
you know,
without any possession and this is how we are going to end no matter what you do
in your life or with your life.
Those are really heavy kind of experiences.
Uh,
uh,
so,
I had some of those experiences when either there's a suicidal impulse or even
suicide,
even suicides would not be solution of trying to get out of that state.
And so when I was hitting some of these places in my own sessions,
uh,
I would have like a parade of my patients are,
I would suddenly say,
oh,
this is where it was,
or this is where she was when I was,
when I was bringing just my training as a psychiatrist and things that I've
read,
I realize I was sitting there listening to what they were saying.
I had no clue what they were talking about.
And,
but I got really full experiential understanding by finding those places in
myself.
And this is also interesting about this,
this large map of the psyche.
You know,
that each of us has all those things.
It's not a question of whether you are a psychiatric patient or not.
If you go deep enough,
you,
you find all those elements within yourself,
you are,
if you,
if you are dealing,
you're processing the hours in the birth canal,
you find the whole psychopathology there,
all the emotional problems,
all the psychosomatic symptoms,
the choking,
the,
the nausea,
the headaches,
the,
the paints,
psychosomatic pains in the body.
Uh,
you know,
people frequently telling me they found eight layer inside,
they found stolen.
I mean,
uh,
you,
you discover the shadow aspects.
So,
so the,
the human personality is a little different from what described by mainstream
psychiatry.
Would you,
you and your late wife,
Christina coined the term spiritual emergency.
Uh,
and,
uh,
she found it I guess in 1980,
the spiritual emergence network Sen.
Now I'd love for you to explain what that means,
but then also,
uh,
if you could,
if you could touch on the difference between or differences,
if there are any between spiritual emergencies that are naturally occurring.
Let's just say,
or people
might view as say the onset of schizophrenia and the late twenties or something
like that.
Yeah.
First versus those precipitated by psychedelics.
Whether it concept came from,
uh,
the work with psychedelics and was the,
with the breath work,
you know,
when you realize that,
uh,
people in these situations would have experiences like of a death,
three bursts,
destruction of the birth,
recreation,
a of the world,
you know,
past life experiences and so on.
And,
uh,
I very early,
discovered that there was,
if you have bad trip,
it is no way,
no good way of,
of terminating it.
The worst thing that you can do is what's done routinely,
which has come with tranquilizers when you give tranquilizers to people who are
in a,
on a bad trip and then keep them on maintenance.
Those is,
this prevents any kind of resolution.
If somebody has a bad trip,
uh,
that means that they are dealing with a difficult aspect of their unconscious.
And when it's coming up,
it's coming up for a healing for it's not,
it's not just the drug created this horrible,
horrible experience.
So,
so the way you do it,
you have to tell people,
you know,
the euro in Lsd session,
this is a time limited thing.
I'm going to be here.
And then when something remains unresolved,
we do some,
uh,
body work and some emotional work to bring it to a good closure.
People can benefit from this,
a bad trips.
So I realized very early that when people had difficult experiences,
the last thing I would do is to combine with tranquilizers.
You know,
and so I saw many of those situations where people experience what they would be
hospitalized for in the psychedelic session.
And we,
if we stayed with it,
it actually was a major healing major transformation.
So then the obvious answer was,
you know,
should we treat it differently just because it happened without breathing fast
breathing or because it happened without the psychedelics?
No,
we just,
uh,
you know,
applied to that,
uh,
other category of spontaneously emerging experiences of this kind.
Now,
what is necessary for having this kind of understanding,
you have to have the large map psyche is not just the postnatal biography and
the Freud and,
um,
individual unconscious.
There is the record of,
uh,
these hours of bursts of the,
of the anxiety of the,
of,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
physical discomfort.
And,
uh,
also the,
the amazing,
uh,
aggression,
the fury that is generated in the fetus who cannot breeze and is a,
is subjected to all those torsions and so on.
Uh,
so,
uh,
if you have a,
if you have a map that includes that,
and if you have the map that includes the collective unconscious,
which psychiatry has not accepted the young gay and idea that we have also,
uh,
the collective unconscious as irregular kind of Germane part of our unconscious,
both the historical part of the collective unconscious and the archetypal,
so having visions of archetype will beings are being taken to archetype of
domains like hell or paradise.
Those are common experiences,
uh,
in a,
in the breathwork or in psychedelic sessions.
So this just gives you an idea.
This is a stage that you can work with the way you would work with people in a,
in a psychedelic session.
So,
so that's a perfect segue.
Let's take as a,
as a hypothetical situation and an alternate world where the of psychologists
and psychiatrists have accepted the collective unconscious and,
and have this larger map.
Someone is brought to a hospital by their family because they seem to be having
what the family believes to be a psychotic break,
whether it's schizophrenia or a diet.
However it might be diagnosed currently they're brought to the hospital.
If a,
if a practitioner,
if a doctor or psychologist have this larger map,
what would the intervention or diagnostic process look like?
Potentially?
Uh,
well,
people,
people usually ask me when,
when I say that the concept 32,
two emergency,
uh,
if there are any professional psychiatry psychology,
they say,
can you give me differential diagnosis?
You see,
this is what we did.
And in somatic medicine,
differential diagnosis,
if people have a,
you know,
infection,
you want to find out which infection,
what is the differential diagnosis of,
what is the differential diagnosis between different kinds of diabetes and so
on.
So they would like something like that for spiritual emergency,
which you cannot do because,
uh,
the,
you know,
psychosis,
it's not,
this is not a medical diagnosis.
We,
we can't,
in the exception of the organic,
uh,
psychosis,
we cannot,
um,
uh,
really,
um,
make the diagnosis.
We don't have any findings in the cerebral spinal liquid.
We don't have any findings in the blood.
We don't have any finding in a urine where we can,
you know,
have a litmus paper,
put it in the sample of urine,
says it's comes out,
uh,
you know,
green.
It's a schizophrenia.
You basically the diagnose these different cycles,
so called psychotic states by the fact that people have experiences,
uh,
and behaviors that current model cannot.
But,
but part of those,
uh,
symptoms which are,
which are used as being important,
you know,
diagnostic,
uh,
two,
four,
four psychiatry could be,
for example,
people have the experience of,
of death three boroughs or destruction of the world,
recreation of the,
of the world.
They have experiences.
Uh,
uh,
that seemed to be a past life experiences.
So those are all absolutely normal,
uh,
um,
elements in the,
uh,
human unconscious.
But other understood really in a,
if you want in the graphy and Yogi and a way the,
the,
the psyche is infinitely larger than then a mainstream psychiatry ever
considered.
It's more like the description that you find in the great spiritual philosophies
of the East and induce them Buddhism,
Taoism,
and they have the,
they have the real maps of the psyche because they were focusing,
uh,
you know,
for centuries on systematic exploration of the psyche in a very similar way in
which we do science.
You know,
people,
they were describing certain,
uh,
procedures that you have to follow certain forms of meditation.
They would collect the,
uh,
descriptions of those experiences,
discuss or write about it and so on.
So it's a systematic exploration of the human psyche,
this,
uh,
cultures.
We're not interested in technology,
so they are nowhere close to what we are in terms of the understanding of the
material world,
but a way ahead of us in terms of understanding of consciousness and the,
and the psyche.
And it's very,
you know,
it's very humbling for somebody like myself having a,
professional training and being through a stage when I thought,
what the Shamans are doing,
this other primitives in the jungle somewhere,
you know,
illiterate and so on.
We have our scientific approach,
which is behavior is immoral or psychoanalysis.
Now this,
if you,
if you have the experience of these tools that the Shamans have available,
you develop a lot of respect to that and
related to that.
But the question is,
is it has to be harnessed.
You know,
and that's not an easy,
easy task in the,
um,
industry civilization.
You would have to change first.
He would have to change the,
the paradigm,
which is a difficult thing.
You probably know that the,
the shift from the geocentric system to the heliocentric system after Copernicus
is,
uh,
you know,
published this about the revolutions of the planets.
It took over a hundred years.
And the,
the,
uh,
resistance,
it was not just the church.
This was,
the resistance was coming also from,
from the universities where there are all kinds of arguments.
Why the,
you know,
why the earth cannot be,
uh,
around and rotate and,
and uh,
you know,
they're around the sun and so on.
For you personally?
How has your experience of your inner world changed over the last,
say,
60 years or after you had your first psychedelic experience?
So you have that experience and you go on to have all of these experiences.
What is your inner,
your experience of your inner world look like?
How's that?
You know,
I was an atheist,
uh,
um,
this goes back to a little scandal in our family.
Uh,
when my parents got a gut,
fell in love and wanted to get married,
it was in a small check down and my father's feminity was,
had no a religious affiliation and my mother's feminine will stick to the
Catholic.
And so the church refused to marry them because my father was taken by the
definition and this was great.
A lot of turmoil.
It's almost,
seems like it would not happen until the solution came.
Uh,
my,
um,
mother's,
uh,
parents made a batch of donation to the church and then suddenly they relax
their standards and they allowed that.
And,
uh,
they had a business on main street and uh,
so when,
when the wedding happened,
they could roll out carpets across the street,
stopped the traffic,
and to take the carpets to the,
to the altar so the guests could go from the altar all the way to the house in
Everett banquet there.
And my parents got so upset by this that they decided not to commit me or my
brother to any religion.
It,
we should make our own decisions when we come of age.
So we actually had classes of religion,
but for me it was always a three hour.
Why would go for a walk or read their book or if they were sort of playing
soccer summer,
I would join them.
You know,
being glad that I had this extra time.
But also I was very curious creature.
I was,
I was also missing,
this was called,
uh,
I think very DZ and morale or something like this where the classes and David,
they were being taught something that I was missing.
So I was kind of a little ambivalent about it.
But then from this kind of background,
I went to medical school at the time when they hit the Marxist regime,
we were controlled by the Soviet Union.
So we really got the pure materialistic doctrine.
You can't,
you can't get,
uh,
you know,
more materialistic than that.
So,
uh,
it was my first LSD session.
They just changed that.
And,
uh,
you know,
I was one kind of person in the morning and another person walked out of there,
uh,
in the evening,
I was really basically open to the,
to the mystical world.
I saw that,
you know,
that was a much deeper understanding that,
that anything that,
uh,
that my,
formal training provided.
So,
uh,
so this the paradox,
which I was aware of it when I was coming down as a,
as a believe,
sort of not believing,
but the mystical mystical person,
I differentiate quite a bit.
Spirituality from religion never became a religious in any way.
I became very spiritual.
And,
uh,
I realized the paradox,
you know,
it's,
uh,
the,
the divine sort of comes to me in an experiment in a,
in a Marxist,
a country,
you know,
induced by this substance from a Swiss chemist.
Uh,
but I knew,
I felt I was stuck in psychiatry and I was at that point,
not very excited about psychiatry.
Uh,
but I,
I felt coming down from the session,
I felt the fire.
I'm psychiatry.
This is by far the most interesting thing I can study.
So if you look at my professional career,
there is nothing.
There was a year,
60 years,
you know,
that,
uh,
I have done that would not be in one way or another related to these holotropic
states.
That became what I said was by my passion,
my vocation,
my,
my profession.
Is there any particular synchronicity or experience in any of the holotropic
states that you've experienced yourself that,
that you find the hardest to explain or the most,
uh,
unusual.
Slash remarkable?
Does it,
does it,
does anything come to mind?
Uh,
I don't know.
You,
I have so many,
so many of them.
Uh,
I think when have
pick one.
Yeah,
you could do,
you can choose more than one too.
One of the wildest one was actually the first question that I had in when I came
to Baltimore from Prague.
It was a process where my,
a request to for the scholarship was first turned down.
And then,
uh,
then,
I appealed.
And then,
uh,
I had a very powerful psychedelic session with a colleague of mine,
a psychiatrist,
and uh,
this was a major,
major death rebirth opening can what I experienced.
It's like,
you know,
kind of Atman Brahman,
uh,
experience.
And uh,
I came back home and,
uh,
in the mailbox was the positive response I can,
I can go to the United States.
So it,
within very short time I packed,
I ended up,
you know,
it's 40 pounds of my luggage.
I took all my records with me,
25,
25 pounds,
15 pounds of personal belonging.
And I was going to Baltimore.
And in Baltimore we had the permission to give sessions to professionals and
collecting the information from that.
And so I had a session,
we qualified for that ourselves.
And in that session I suddenly had the feeling,
uh,
that,
I was not bound by space and time that I somehow could get to other places in
the world if I decide to,
uh,
and I wanted to put it to a test.
I said,
can I,
for example,
get to Prague
into,
into the,
uh,
apartment of my parents?
And so I imagine,
you know,
which direction it was,
pride and how far an imagined myself sort of flying in that direction.
And I was experience of flight,
but I was not getting anywhere.
So I felt there was a problem there and I was thinking about it.
And then I realized that I was
limited by this,
by the constant,
this,
the court in its spatial temporal coding is I believe that practice in this
direction,
uh,
you know,
and a certain kind of distance that I have to overcome.
And just imagine that I am,
I'm in Prague.
And what happened the next time I was suddenly trapped in some kind of very
strange space where they were like,
uh,
circuits on transistors and stuff.
Uh,
and I didn't know what was happening.
And then I realized I was inside of the television of,
uh,
the,
the television set of my,
of my parents.
And I was thinking about it and I had to laugh because I was still holding on to
the next element of the materialistic world.
The only way you can really see what's happening in other places.
You,
you need a television unit,
you need a camera and a satellite,
you see.
So I realized I am not even bound by that.
I'm,
I'm in,
uh,
in,
the,
the world of spirit.
I can just has to say,
now I am there and I'm there.
And then in the,
at that point it turned kind of inside out.
And I was walking,
I felt straight.
I didn't feel,
it didn't feel,
I was in a session and I was walking in the department.
I heard my parents breathing and I went to the,
to,
uh,
the window.
And,
uh,
there,
there on the corner was a clock and it was showing this the six hour difference,
uh,
which,
I thought for awhile and I said,
not,
not approve,
you know,
um,
uh,
I,
I knew it that there was a difference that my mind could fabricate that.
So how do I prove that this really happened?
And I said I would go and take a picture of the wall and then check what my
parents said.
There was something strange happened to,
you know,
if we found this painting on the,
uh,
you know,
on the floor and,
uh,
this nail was still in the wall.
And so I started walking to the,
and reaching for that.
And then suddenly I had the feeling that I was gambling.
I was,
I was playing,
uh,
like a ruler with my,
with my soul.
That was,
this was very dangerous.
Every,
the feeling that,
uh,
I was getting sort of under the influence of some evil forces.
And then I realized how much they warn you if you are under spiritual quest,
uh,
from that,
that period where you start playing with these mind over,
you know,
the cds and so on.
And a,
I started seeing,
I started thinking images,
what I could do,
if I really have the possibility I could go and eavesdrop and political meetings
in the world,
you know,
uh,
I could get access to scientific secrets and so on.
I could go to a casino,
I could beat the casino and so on.
And,
uh,
I realized there was a,
there was a real danger from the ego to,
to start playing with the possibility of having this power.
So I finally sort of didn't have the courage to do that.
And also didn't want to be in a world where this would be possible because if I
had the power than other people had the power and then the,
the doors don't protect me.
I mean a world sort of,
uh,
you know,
this kind of wild western and I didn't,
didn't want that proof that this is this what's really possible.
And I went,
I lied down on a couch.
Uh,
we're actually,
uh,
I was coming down from a session before going to,
to Baltimore,
and I was lying then.
And then this horrible thought came to me.
Uh,
maybe I never got to ball team or I am just like fabricated that trip to,
to the United States in my LSD session.
I'm now coming down,
uh,
from,
from the session.
I never left,
you see,
so I was like the trunk.
So in that situation,
you know,
am I a butterfly having the dream of being a human or a human,
having the,
um,
the feeling that I'm butterfly.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I was stuck in that place for a while where I was not sure whether I was having
astral projection from Baltimore or whether I was a,
I was coming down from the session.
So that was the wildest one probably.
And of course then coming back I was cursing myself.
You know,
what a wasted opportunity for a great experiments,
you know,
the proof,
uh,
Esther protection,
and uh,
but the fear and the metaphysical fear that I was really sort of,
uh,
you know,
losing my soul in that too.
So I started playing with these kinds of forces
that,
that last part of that experience in particular sounds terrible though.
The laying down or terrifying I should say,
laying down on the,
on the couch in Prague and wondering,
like you said,
if the entire trip to the United States had been a fabrication when you came out
of that experience,
how quickly did it take or how long did it take for you to realize that in fact
you are back in the United States
eight hours?
So I was absolutely clear,
you know,
read back to California.
Yeah,
yeah.
If,
if you were starting your career,
just,
just a few more questions.
You've been so generous with your time,
but if you were starting again right now and,
uh,
you are a promising young scientist,
you could research anything you wanted.
Let's assume that all of these compounds are legal.
Uh,
what would you focus on?
What type of studies would you want to do,
or what type of research would you want to do?
Well,
you know,
one of the problems with this,
uh,
renaissance that a lot of this is repeating things which were already done.
Like the cancer projects are great,
but,
uh,
we did it to the point when that when we ask for more money for continuing the
research,
they say,
you have already proved it.
Now it has to go to the hospitals.
So it has to be used.
And,
uh,
so,
you know,
those also,
this wonderful study at Johns Hopkins is just a more sophisticated and
methodologically better,
uh,
you know,
Walter Pankey experiment,
which had some flaws that,
but I would love to see this now going to the research of creativity to bring
people,
um,
you know,
biology's quantum relativistic physicists and see what they can do.
As,
you know,
we have indications that the whole development of computers was closely
connected with the use of psychedelics.
You know,
people like Duck Engelbart and uh,
and uh,
even,
you know,
Steve Jobs and all these people made it absolutely clear.
Uh,
there was a statement that uh,
uh,
all the people to one,
two men and a woman who developed virtual reality where acid hats.
So,
and this is now,
you know,
understood.
There is a,
there is a possibility of sort of loosening somehow the,
the blocks that we have in problem solving because we are stuck with a paradigm.
Know Thomas Kuhn wrote that fantastic book,
the structure of scientific revolutions showing that the history of science is
not a linear development where we started from not knowing anything and then
each generation edit a little of the observations and they were,
you know,
more and more accurate a hypotheses and theories created.
So that what we have now,
the understanding of the universe is the,
is the best understanding that has ever been in,
you know,
in any,
at any time in any society.
And it showed that it's a,
it's a joke that the development of science breaks into these distinct periods
and each of them is governed.
But what he calls a paradigm,
you know,
a way of,
uh,
looking,
looking at the world,
you know,
certain basic metaphysical assumptions,
uh,
beliefs,
ways of,
uh,
what are relevant,
areas to research.
How do you do research?
How you evaluated this is all paradigm,
uh,
the tide.
So the examples of course,
I already mentioned the,
the shift from a geocentric to the heliocentric system.
There was a one,
a revolution in chemistry where they had focused on chemistry where there was
this,
the royal substance of focused on.
And then when people like,
uh,
like a delta or Lavoie Zia came with the idea of atoms,
you know,
uh,
people at problems because they didn't believe in,
in flogging stone anymore.
Now we laugh when they hear that.
And then of course,
the,
the first three decades in the 20th century,
the physicist had to go through this incredible,
uh,
conceptual cataclysm moving from Newton first to the theories of relativity and
then to quantum physics that even Einstein,
who initiated or couldn't accept that until his death.
So this is,
this is the question of paradigm.
So I believe that we are now in the period of paradigm shift,
uh,
in relation to consciousness and the human psyche that's comparable in the
nature and scope to what the physicists had to,
uh,
experience in the first three decades of the 20th century.
And then in a sense,
it can be soon as being complimentary to the changes that already happened in
the understanding of matter.
You know,
the quantum physicists,
uh,
who are my friends said no,
no problems relating to my observation.
It was mostly the resistance of psychiatrists and psychologists.
So one more thing,
one more thing.
Uh,
uh,
so there is the,
the situation that couldn't describe it during the time when you have the
science dominated by a paradigm,
the scientists do what he called,
uh,
um,
normal science,
which is problem solving within the context of a given parameters.
It's like playing chess.
If you play chess,
you have to follow the rules.
You can't suddenly take an inconvenient figure and throw it out of the,
uh,
out of the chess board,
you know?
Uh,
and then he describes what happens then when,
when observations come the challenge,
the paradigm,
how is,
uh,
rejected.
Initially people are called crazy or it's called fraud or whatever.
And then when it comes,
keeps coming,
then finally realization there is a problem.
And then the wilder theorists come and the first they are sort of rejected.
And after awhile the new paradigm emerges and is accepted by the scientific
community.
And then history is rewritten because now you have new heroes,
people who already saw it,
you know,
centuries ago.
The way we see it now about,
uh,
what I would like to add was then,
Gregory Bateson edit.
And other thing is this the,
not only do the scientists believe in,
in that paradigm are committed to it,
but they believe that it's an accurate and exhaustive description of reality,
per se.
Not a map,
not the best way we can sort of currently organize the observation that we have.
It is a definitive description of how things are.
And,
uh,
this is,
this is called the confusion between the map and the territory.
People like Arthur core,
zip ski.
And then Gregory Bateson was very,
very big about it and,
uh,
Gregory was laughing about it.
He says,
if scientists make a arrows like that,
it can happen that one day they come to the restaurant and they eat the menu
instead of the thinner,
the relationship between the paradigm,
you know.
And uh,
the territory that it described is that is a very much like a reading the
manual.
So I had this question I wanted to ask this entire conversation since we first
started speaking and uh,
let me,
let me just get my facts straight before I ask it.
Are you currently 87?
Is that accurate?
What is your current age?
Uh,
I just wanted to,
1st of July I was just,
was,
uh,
was uh,
87,
87.
Well,
happy belated birthday and thank you.
Go.
Thank you very much.
You are remarkably,
uh,
I'd be incredibly sharp,
incredibly energetic.
I mean more so than some 20 somethings.
I know.
What do you attribute that to?
I mean our r and d two,
what factors,
I mean,
are you,
are both,
we're both of your parents sharp their entire lives.
I mean,
I,
I aspire currently I'm 40,
I'm 41 and I would love to have half the energy that you do.
So what to what do you attribute that it's,
it's really,
uh,
just,
I mean mind blowing to me.
Uh,
I'm so inspired,
I just trying to absorb some of the enthusiasm and energy that you have in his
phone in this phone call.
I think,
you know,
part of it is that I'm really,
really very,
very deeply committed to this,
uh,
to this,
idea of,
uh,
these holotropic states to,
to bring them into psychiatry,
to bring them into society.
I had a lot of,
uh,
you know,
meetings with,
uh,
Albert Hoffman who,
who was talking about the new LLCs to create a situation where these are
integrated into social fabric.
They are socially sanctioned.
That we can sort of use it the way ancient Greeks.
The Loc is a Mr is,
uh,
you know,
you probably know this was done for two years in the lenses.
So they had to offer something pretty impressive too,
to keep the attention of the ancient world.
And,
uh,
the,
a list of people who have been initiates in these mysteries.
It reads like,
who is who in antiquity.
I mean,
it includes Plato,
Aristotle,
Cicero wrote about it,
you know,
mark was already,
it's been Darras and,
uh,
all these people.
So we all sort of say,
you know,
the Greeks are very talented,
beautiful art,
beautiful science,
and a great ideas.
No,
the fact that,
uh,
you know,
so many people every five years at,
uh,
some powerful experiences,
puts it into somewhat different perspective.
And a Albert Hofmann and Gordon was the one who brought the,
the mushrooms from Mexico,
from the muscle,
take Indians and Carl Rock,
a Greek scholar.
They wrote the book road to LMC.
So when they found out that the key to these mysteries was Kiki on k,
and they found out that this was a,
um,
psychedelic portion,
which was made of,
uh,
of Erica,
very similar to LSD.
So it's again,
imagined,
uh,
it's so many people,
every five years in that smaller world had psychedelic experiences that it could
have had some impact on the,
uh,
on the culture.
You know,
the last time when we were in,
uh,
in [inaudible],
there was,
uh,
a guide and there are the,
the ruins of,
uh,
of the telestream on which is the building where this was happening and it's a
gigantic building.
And I ask,
how many people were having these experiences here at a time?
You said,
at least,
you know,
in the,
in the last stage,
3000 people every five years,
we are getting this,
this dose of this.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you know,
when I,
when I read Plato now,
I don't see him like pacing in the academy and say,
go,
let me see how the world works.
You know,
we have not done this,
but there's this level of the,
with the archetypes.
And so this is something that you can explore.
You can experience archetypes in a,
in psychedelic session.
So these are all,
all,
uh,
the philosophy was inspired by,
by psychedelic experiences.
What do you,
what do you think humanity needs most right now?
And you,
in your opinion,
if that's what people,
do you have any big question?
Yeah.
What,
what,
what do you think humanity needs most right now?
What we need?
Yeah.
If there's any particular type of change or shift the,
no,
I haven't met him.
Okay.
Well,
we,
I think,
you know,
the,
uh,
the monastery materialistic paradigm,
I think it's the really destroying this,
uh,
this planet.
And we have a,
you know,
we have philosophy,
experiential spirituality that people have really,
the experience don't have,
uh,
have,
spiritual experiences,
which are nondenominational,
which are a non chauvinistic nonsectarian,
which are universal,
all inclusive,
all uh,
or,
um,
uh,
embracing to people who have these,
these direct spiritual experiences.
They,
they don't experience division in the world.
You know,
the,
what happened with the,
with the great organized religions is that they,
they,
uh,
unite people who are willing to see it the same way and worship the same way.
Uh,
but at the same time divide the world because they set it against another group
which have taken sort of different archetypes in different,
uh,
different ways of worshiping.
So then you have a situation where,
you know,
we are Christians,
you all other guys are pagans and there's,
we really have to convert you or there's really not a good place for you here.
Or we are,
uh,
Muslims and you guys all are infidels.
Let go that have sacred word against the infidels.
You know,
we have juice you are going in and so on.
And then you have even these kinds of divisions within the same religion.
There's centuries of bloodshed between Protestants and Catholics.
And you have the same with the Sunni and the Shia.
They killing each other,
destroying their own temples.
Now these are not religions that will help us in this situation in the world.
Uh,
but this is very different with the spirituality,
which is really taking,
taking everything in and it changes,
it changes,
you know,
consciousness in a way that people embrace the,
uh,
the ecological movement.
They realize we have to treat nature in a different way.
Because we are so vitally embedded in [inaudible] and entangled in,
in nature that we will not use nature as commodity.
You know,
something that should serve as a and uh,
the expense of,
of,
you know,
destroying the,
storing our environment.
This,
uh,
this,
you know,
nothing that's more important for us.
We are biological creatures.
We need air,
we need water and we need clean soil where we are growing our food.
It's,
it's,
it's a soul.
So suicidal,
so self destructive to destroy the basis on which we depend as uh,
you know,
there should not be anything keeping the environment supporting,
uh,
life.
No,
no.
You know,
economic profit,
no,
no political,
no military order.
We should really realize that we are in the same boat.
You know,
whoever is destroying the environment is,
is uh,
destroying us.
And there are many places people can find of course,
writing and more about you.
Stanislav grof.com.
I'll link to all of this in the show notes for people.
So they'll be able to find that at Tim.
Dot.
Blog slash podcast and I certainly recommend that people check out your books,
including when the impossible happens.
I,
a friend of mine who involved in scientific research recommended I read the
cosmic game.
And,
uh,
I'm wondering if before we wrap up,
maybe could you share one more story,
uh,
any story that,
that,
uh,
to folks out there who are wondering if there might be more to the story than
just the,
the purely material,
sort of a hyper rational,
materialistic worldview.
There might just be more to the story.
I'm wondering if there's anything else that you can share.
I remember the coming across the pig,
God,
his story.
I mean,
there are so many to choose from.
Uh,
but
yeah,
let me,
let me do one that's kind of,
I think he's,
uh,
you know,
has a larger kind of importance than,
than just mentioning one of and clinical story and sold.
So a story from when the impossible happens and it has to do with the experience
that I had in a peyote ceremony.
So when I came to the United States,
you know,
I heard about [inaudible] and so on.
I never had a chance being in,
in a Czechoslovakia and not having the possibility of traveling to have the
Toyota experience.
So I was very interested in that.
And we had this program for professionals.
Um,
one of the programs at the Maryland Psychiatric Research Center,
and,
uh,
the,
one of the persons who came and was a Ken Godfrey,
who was the psychiatrist at the Va Hospital in Topeka,
Kansas.
He was himself,
uh,
you know,
native American and his wife was native American and he was running a
psychedelic program in,
in,
uh,
in Topeka.
Uh,
but he didn't have anybody to sit for him.
So he came for his own session and I sit in history psychedelic session.
So,
you know,
we became very,
very close.
And so when,
uh,
after his last session,
we were talking,
I said,
Ken,
is there any possibility you can get me into a native American church ceremony?
And he says,
I will try.
And then he called in a few days and say,
you know,
I talked to the road chief,
uh,
and you can come and you can bring four of your friends.
So anyway,
we sort of got into the airplane and flew to Topeka and then drove into to the
middle of the Kansas prairie there.
And there were these teepees and uh,
this,
uh,
the ceremony was being prepared and we had to go through kind of a clearance
that they wanted to find out what kind of people we were.
We had to tell them about ourselves and we go just a lot of aggressive comments
from them about,
uh,
how,
you know,
white people came and they,
uh,
they have,
taken their land.
They had killed their buffalo,
they're killed,
they're warriors,
they have raped a,
their women and so on.
And so there was a sort of,
almost like an encounter group.
And as we were going on,
they were sort of finding out that we were okay and one after another that we
can participate.
And at the end there was just one very sort of dark solid men who wouldn't have
any of us.
We had,
we were like Pale faces and that was it,
you know,
is not going to ever in the sacred ceremony.
And then he get onto a lot of peer pressure.
It was time to start and people say,
come on,
you know,
let it go.
And so he did say yes,
but it was really no,
and I was a in the tp,
I was sitting across him and then,
uh,
the,
the buttons,
two buttons where we're a past and a,
then it started coming on and he sort of was really like radiating like a laser
beam toward me.
You know,
the hey treat was kind of an,
everything was amplified of course by the,
by a pot.
And we were doing the rounds.
When you pass a staff and a drum and every time you get it,
you can say something,
you can sing a song or invite people to do something or make a confession or
whatever,
but you can also pass.
And every time it came to him he would grab it.
And push it.
He just would not participate.
And so we will all these rounds and we were going through the Ras last round,
um,
where everybody can say something and a probably high who was a,
another LSD therapist from,
from a Maryland working with us,
Helen Bonnie and her sister Helen Bonny was our music therapist and Walter Use
Clark was very famous,
a professor of religion.
And uh,
so as we were doing the last round,
uh,
water use in Clark gave this,
you know,
almost like masochistic,
a kind of a speech.
He said how wonderful it was from your,
you know,
brothers and sisters to take us into the sacred ceremony after what we have done
to you have killed your buffalo and your warriors and rape your women and taking
your spirituality.
And then somehow,
I don't remember except exactly the context he mentioned me and said,
especially stand here,
who was so far from his native Czechoslovakia.
And suddenly when he mentioned that it was like a lightning hit this guy and he
started shaking,
he got up,
he threw himself into my lab at put,
put his head into my lab,
sort of not,
what's the tears were running out of his eyes and,
and,
you know,
snot out of his nose.
It became like one of our workshops that we sort of close work with people and
everybody was watching,
nobody knew what was happening and this was happening for awhile.
And then he got up and went back to his place,
sit down and not,
not talking,
just sitting there.
And there was like a lot of,
lot of pressure,
you know,
psychological pressure,
people wanting to know what was happening.
And then he sits,
you know,
uh,
I have to say something horrible.
I thought you were all Americans.
I didn't know Stan was from Czechoslovakia.
You know,
the checks are not known as your archetype of Raiders of the wild west.
Exactly.
So his,
I treated him,
uh,
as a,
as if we were an American and I hated him through the whole ceremony.
And,
uh,
it's just more,
more than I can,
I can take,
you know,
and,
uh,
then what sitting there and,
it was clear that something more was coming.
And then he said,
but it's worse than that.
During the Second World War,
I was drafted in the American air force and I was personally present in the air
raid on his city.
There was five days before the end of the war.
There was an American,
a attack on and that destroyed the automobile factory there and damaged pills.
So he stayed home.
But I went and I killed his people.
Our roles were reversed.
And that's just too much for me.
And then he got up and he went to the four Americans there and embrace them.
He says,
uh,
you are not my enemies.
You are,
you are my friends.
He says,
we are all in the same boat.
We,
if we,
if we hold the old grudges,
uh,
we,
we all die.
We have,
we are all
children of mother earth.
And we have to,
we have to sort of,
uh,
really sort of learn how to,
how to live with each other.
And how to love each other.
And then he ended in his says,
well,
they believe in reincarnation.
So says,
well,
for what I can say when this was happening,
I might have been on the other side.
And you know,
we were still still under the influence of priorities.
So we were all crying and sort of embracing each other.
And that was fear of reconciliation was amazing.
I actually told that story at the,
at the end of,
uh,
the international transpersonal conference in Prague when I was bringing
transpersonal psychology back to Prague because we had all these,
you know,
European nations that had all kinds of grudges and really didn't like each
other.
Like we were occupied by Nazi Germany for six years,
you know,
a lot of people killed and it up in the concentration camps.
Then we had years of,
uh,
Communist.
Uh,
they're in,
so nobody liked a Russian,
none,
none of the people from the eastern European countries,
like either Russia or Germany.
We had sort of German and Jews there.
And,
uh,
what was amazing that we did a large holotropic breathwork,
you know,
that'd be for the conference as a,
as a pre conference workshop.
And it was amazing how within within two days,
I mean,
some of these boundaries where were melting and you know,
people embracing each other and,
uh,
sitting for each other.
And when people were owning their own emotional problems,
they actually activated the best in other people.
And in spite of language difficulties and so on,
there was really a change of the,
of the atmosphere,
uh,
from,
you know,
all these antagonisms that were certainly in the air at the beginning.
What a wonderful story.
So anyway,
that's my story.
Thank you.
Psychotic,
less lesson in forgiveness.
I think we could all use lessons and forgiveness not only towards others,
but towards ourselves.
And I really want to express gratitude.
Uh,
and thanks certainly,
uh,
for the experiences that I've had,
which had been informed by your writing and,
uh,
people who have,
indirectly or directly been trained by you in some respects.
And,
uh,
to thank you on behalf of no doubt,
many people who are listening who have had similar experiences.
And,
uh,
I get,
I'm very,
I very cautiously optimistic about this,
this renaissance that we're witnessing and hopefully we won't repeat some of the
same mistakes that appear to have been made,
but the social circumstances are so different.
And,
uh,
we really appreciate you taking the time today.
Uh,
I certainly hope this isn't our last conversation.
but,
uh,
I want to be respectful of your time and we've,
we've gone for quite,
quite a bit already today.
Is there anything else that you would like to say to the people listening,
uh,
we're asking of them before we,
before we end this particular conversation?
Well,
maybe it'll repeat,
you know what the colleague was stuff young said that I would really endorse
that.
Uh,
it's important that we live our life not just sort of by responding to what is
happening outside of us,
but spending some time in some kind of focus.
The self exploration and the yen debt can read too in a transformation.
So we live our life as a synthesis of what we see outside and what comes from
within it would say you,
you get lessons from what he called the self,
the higher I aspect of our hour personality.
So,
you know,
part of the,
part of the problem of the industrial civilization,
we lost this,
uh,
this,
tradition,
uh,
off if you want of psychonautics all the other groups of humanity way back
probably into the Palaeolithic.
They were,
they weren't using these holotropic states for healing,
for,
uh,
you know,
transformation for the main main vehicle for ritual,
a spiritual,
uh,
alive.
They weren't using it for a lot of,
uh,
practical things as an inspiration for,
for art and so on.
So,
um,
I see this a distributor brand as the renaissance that is happening now,
not just this correcting of these,
of these,
you know,
uh,
really,
terrible administrative legal mistakes that were done that stopped the research
for 40 years.
I returned to the research.
Uh,
I see it also as,
uh,
the,
the possibility of the industrial civilization to join the rest of humanity.
That always was combining somehow the,
these,
uh,
spiritual,
inner spiritual ritual experiences with whatever they were doing in the,
in the external world.
Well,
thank you so much.
Uh,
uh,
again,
Tim,
thank you so much for everything you have been,
you have been doing and uh,
thank you for this,
for this opportunity to,
you know,
share some of my life.
It was with your listeners.
It's such a pleasure and uh,
I can only aspire to,
uh,
contribute in some small way.
Uh,
and I'm excited to see,
uh,
what you do from this point forward and you seem to have as much energy as ever
traveling around the world doing what you do.
And I hope we can have many,
many more conversations and uh,
but,
but for today,
I want to be respectful of your time since you do have so many things going on.
And I will certainly in the show notes to everybody listening,
uh,
link to everything we've discussed,
all of the books,
the different websites,
foundations and so on.
And you can find all those at tim.blog/podcast.
Uh,
Stan,
thank you so much.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Again,
it's wonderful.
It's great to have,
uh,
an interview or you know,
who knows what we are talking about.
It doesn't,
it doesn't always happen.
I suppose one of the great ones.
Thank you so much.
I really,
really appreciate it and to everybody listening,
keep your mind open and look outside but also look inside as Stan mentioned.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Fridays.
A very short email where I share the coolest things I found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the,
as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom,
which more than 2 million Americans have used to help start their businesses.
Past guests even such as well,
wordpress lead developer,
CEO of Automattic,
Matt Mullenweg now valued at more than billion dollars,
have used legal zoom to help their business needs.
Specifically in his case to form this company butts.
Legal Zoom isn't just for launching your business.
Their services include everything from helping you to manage changing tax laws,
reviewing contracts,
creating Ndas,
nondisclosure agreements,
important stuff,
handling lease agreements and it's this thing with really any other legal
challenge,
hurdle,
inconvenience that typically takes time and effort away from running your
business.
The best part is that you won't get charged by the hour because legal zoom isn't
a law firms so they won't be running the clock up and spinning circles just to
raise your bill.
Instead they just ask you to pay one low upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get all the card style,
so visit legal zoom.com and check out their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings,
that's the terminology in the copy that they suggest.
I don't know what the special savings is folks,
but it's titillating.
If you want special savings,
enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout capital t lowercase I am again,
take a peek legal zoom.com and enter Promo Code Tim,
this episode is brought to you by Peloton,
which I've been using [inaudible] for about a year now.
Peloton is a cutting edge indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home.
You can also do on demand,
which is what I do and we'll come back to them so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute.
I,
for instance,
have a Peloton bike right in my master bedroom at home and it's one of the first
things I do.
Many mornings I wake up and meditate for a bit.
Then I knock out a short 20 minute ride in my undies.
Hard to do that at the gym,
take a shower and I'm in higher gear for the rest of the day.
It's really convenient and has become something that I look forward to see.
You have a lot of options for one if you'd like.
You can ride live with thousands of other writers across the country on an
interactive leaderboard to keep him motivated.
There are also up to 14 new classes added every day with more than 8,000 classes
on demand and you can pick based on length,
45 minutes,
20 minutes,
whatever music,
hip hop,
rock and roll or say low impact versus high intensity or interval.
You can pick the class structure and style that works for you and in my case I
quite like now we'll birds and I tend to do on demand and listened to a lot of
and watch many of the same classes over and over,
but I'm kind of promiscuous and also enjoy classes from a lot of the other
instructors.
They have Peloton and amazing roster of incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and personalities so you can find what you're
looking for.
You also get real time metrics that you can use to track your performance over
time and that will help,
I would say catalyze you to beat your personal best.
Now that all sounds good,
right?
Gamification,
Yada,
Yada.
I didn't think that it would work for me or in any way incentivize me,
but they really 100% hit the nail on the head.
I was very,
very impressed with how motivating it was and it worked tremendously to keep me
pushing,
which quite honestly it takes a fair amount.
I can get quite lazy,
particularly with anything that edges on endurance,
which is kind of more than five reps of anything for me.
So check it out.
Discover this cutting edge indoor cycling bike that brings a studio experience
right to your home Peloton is offering listeners to this podcast,
a limited time offer.
Go to one hello [inaudible] dot com that's [inaudible],
O and e Peloton,
p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim,
all caps at checkout and get $100 off of accessories with your Peloton bike
purchase.
So get a great workout at home anytime you want.
Check it out.
Go to one Peloton [inaudible] dot com and use the code Tim,
to get started.